[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
très très bien ma caméra qui est pas
tout à fait cadré voilà c'est mieux et
c'est bien moi blue salut à tous salut
Neo bisous ce week-end et Blue salut à
tous c'est aussi
du coup
aujourd'hui j'ai quelques nouveautés
pour vous alors vous savez qu'hier en
début de stream et ben on avait commencé
par suivre Laurent puis Étienne Bacro et
ensuite on était passé dans la division
1 ou un on avait suivi notamment
Carlson qui a joué contre karwana et
fille qui a joué contre saw et bien
aujourd'hui ce qui va se passer c'est
que j'ai réussi à avoir les caméras donc
pas de pas de jeu de mots pas de film
juste j'ai réussi à avoir les caméras et
ça c'est c'est pas des blagues regardez
bien un petit peu j'ai préparé toutes
les scènes aujourd'hui j'ai pris du
temps pour le faire on a ici l'orange
aussi
mais qui va jouer contre
qui est un des médaillé d'or des
Olympiades avec
l'Ouzbékistan donc gros gros match euh
qu'on va avoir là avec Laurent qui va
commencer avec les couleurs normalement
je suis entre
le troisième division donc était ma
grosse vous savez que avec le système
que j'ai pour cheesecom par rapport aux
caméras je peux mettre que du temps
de chez Laurent et de chez yakubo F
ouais désolé j'ai j'ai pas supprimer le
son des caméras seulement c'est fait
normalement c'est bon
du coup ce que je disais c'est que je
peux pas passer de Division 1 2 et 3 en
fait pour les caméras donc comme la
division 1 bah c'est ça ira ça qui en
finale aujourd'hui contre carcène qui
jouera plus tard d'ailleurs hein
en lui disant deux on a Laurent
Freyssinet et en division 3 et ben on a
Étienne pas trop et ben comme ils sont
chacun dans une division différente et
ben malheureusement je ne peux pas avoir
la caméra de tous ces joueurs en même
temps c'est division par division donc
pour l'instant je suis dans la division
2 avec Laurent qui va commencer d'ici
une minute et
et
on pourrait avoir un peu ce que fait
Étienne Bacro en même temps on aura pas
la caméra sur RTL par contre si Laurent
est éliminé et que Étienne non et ben
pour aller voir et prendre la caméra des
tiennes aussi et quand une fois que ce
sera fini et ben on passera au à la
division 1 avec 6 roues qui est en
finale bien oui en finale contre contre
47 donc c'est qu'il y a plusieurs types
de finale dans ces événements ben ça
sera la finale des gagnants qui
qualifiera avec la finale enfin la
grande finale qui aura lieu dimanche
donc voilà c'est quand même une grosse
partie et je vais voir si j'ai si j'ai
mes parties je crois que tu es parti
sont en train de se lancer
et j'ai toujours pas la partie de
Laurent pour l'instant
dès que je l'ai je vous dis de toute
façon et puis on la suit on a là pour ça
alors les brackets je peux pas vous les
montrer les brackets des des divisions 2
et 3 j'ai pas de de trucs sur enfin j'ai
pas de d'affiche mais pour vous dire là
c'est le deuxième tour c'est la ronde 2
des brackets par contre important en cas
de victoire de Laurent qui a deux
parties aller-retour et éventuellement
un magazon en cas d'égalité en cas de
victoire de Laurent et ben Laurent sera
qualifié pour la ronde la ronde 3 qui va
juste après donc on a deux parties de
Laurent et
potentiellement
4 même potentiellement 6 si jamais il
fait un partage à chaque fois
alors je suis en train de chercher j'ai
toujours pas la partie de Laurent mais
les parties sont en train de se lancer
au fur et à mesure et
où c'est qu'un petit retard et un petit
délai à chaque fois entre chaque partie
on a l'impression que l'angle est en
train de réfléchir ah ça y est c'est
parti et ça a peut-être commencé un ou
pas est-ce que ça a commencé
je ne sais pas en tout cas on est sur la
partie Laurent a bien les blancs dans
cette première
et la partie n'a pas encore débuté mais
ça va commencer très très vite donc Oran
qui a des blancs contre il y a coup bof
alors que dans la division 1 vous avez
pas encore fait on est quand même là de
base pour voir la division 1 je vous
fais très rapidement avant de voir la
partie de Laurent qui va commencer
d'ailleurs qu'il y a commencé avec des
cadres très vite pour le bracket on a 45
filles ou qui sont en finale qui diront
plus tard d'ici environ une heure une
heure et demie et on a qui se joue en
même temps on a les divisions 1 les
loosers des quarts finales on a ce
contrôleur
qui sont en train de jouer en ce moment
même mais nous on préfère bien sûr
suivre nos Français
en plus Laurent qui est qui est très
souvent sur cheescom avec moi pour
commenter donc donc c'est cool de le
suivre d'ailleurs il m'a promis que si
ça se passait bien et ben il pourrait
peut-être venir après nous voir sur la
chaîne par se faire un petit coucou et
débriefer rapidement c'est parti donc
très sympa en tout cas je l'ai eu hier
donc Laurent on va peut-être le voir
tout à l'heure
donc alors une sorte de gambidame vous
voyez
avec un C5 et A6 une sorte de tarage
et donc pour l'instant une position qui
est qui est assez connue
assez classique on va dire on sort les
pièces on prend le centre
comment est-ce qu'on continue ici donc
là il y a plusieurs possibilités je
pense qu'il y a un C4 qui doit pouvoir
il va pouvoir être jouable c'est 4 ici
avec les débutants de se créer une
majorité de ce côté là
mais on peut aussi jouer avec ses 6 sans
faire des pièces normales je pense qu'il
y a plein de coups qui sont possibles
à moi perso j'aime pas jouer avec un
pion isolé donc j'ai envie de ne pas me
laisser manger ici vous comprenez à
cause du pion isolant des 5 mais après à
ce niveau là les joueurs savent tout
faire donc je pense que
salut Arnaud
yes merci à toi merci à toi pour ce
petit message c'est oublié j'ai récupéré
tous les points qui me fallait mais j'ai
tout perdu il y a pas longtemps et j'ai
tout perdu j'ai fait un j'ai fait un
tournoi après avoir reçu mon titre et je
pense que le fait
40 points de perdu je pense que le
contrecoup le soulagement au final m'a
fait faire complètement n'importe quoi
dans mon dernier tournoi mais bon c'est
pas très important le plus important
c'était c'était le titre voilà et le
reste les points et l'eau on s'en fout à
moitié ça regardera quand même
merci Bratt ouais ça les points lourds
ça revient ça va ça vient franchement je
m'en fous un peu à la base j'étais
beaucoup plus
comment dire inquiet quand je voyais que
je fasse des mots en main parce que je
voyais mon objectif de passer 2400 et
donc s'éloigner maintenant que j'ai le
titre franchement je m'en fous un peu et
bon on verra après une fois que j'aurai
bien des réactif de Amy peut-être que je
dirais bah ouais quand même j'aimerais
bien avoir plus de l'eau mais là pour
l'instant je m'en fous
je m'en fous un peu voilà un peu la
caméra je suis donc je suis un petit peu
en dessous ça monte un peu
c'est mieux comme ça ou ça n'a pas
changé
je suis plus dans le cadre
ce qui est bien avec ces caméras c'est
tellement bien cadré qu'on peut voir des
points noirs du front
derrière la mienne j'ai pas beaucoup de
lumière je vois et pourtant
je sais pas comment faire pour essayer
de mettre un peu plus de lumière chez
moi
et la lumière
je vais essayer d'allumer celle-là
j'arrive
ça a pas changé grand chose j'ai
l'impression
salut Estero
qu'elle est bien c'est le contenu en
fait de la caméra surtout qui est bien
je pense mais
c'est un petit peu sombre j'ai
l'impression chez moi alors que pourtant
c'est bien clair
alors donc a été joué cavalier 5 donc
bien entendu je ne peux pas je ne peux
pas manger en E5 à cause de puis on
prend et le pion de 5 qui va tomber
derrière donc ici petit Rock est un
Cooke qui est assez logique
dans cette position j'ai l'impression
petit rock
ok on a un truc
donc je rappelle la cadence on est en 15
+ 3 c'est match aller-retour et et en
cas d'égalité il y aura d'Armageddon
surenchères donc on joue blanc noir il y
a que deux parties dans ces deux
indivision et dans ces poules de perdant
alors que dans la division 1 dans la
poule des gagnants il y a toujours
quatre parties par match
donc on a vu hier que prendre la ventre
temps c'était quand même aussi quelque
chose d'intéressant qui permettait de
mettre la de mettre la pression sur
l'adversaire
[Musique]
et donc ici Laurent pour l'instant qui a
déjà gagné une minute à la pendule et
Laurent qui joue une position assez
tranquille pour l'instant donc cavalier
5 on peut imaginer plus tard une idée
peut-être de jouer F4 avec les Blancs et
de ramener les pièges il y a de la F3 en
F4 c'est un coup qui qui est intéressant
mais qui quand même qu'on avait un petit
peu le fou c'est un qui pourrait plus
passer par la structure donc à ce qui
est de jouer avec avec
la F4 mais après il y aura des idées à
jouer du style F3 et E4 mais quand on
joue F3 4 généralement on va d'abord
peut-être manger en C6 pour pas se faire
doubler les pions ici
donc petit rock avec les jouets F4 par
gamme naturel
généralement quand on joue cavalier 5
souvent c'est pour la lampe-poste mais
aussi pour
pour jouer F4 avoir un super cavalier en
E5 en cas de prise et bon on ferait F1
donc là il y a eu fou des deux c'est la
partie
donc
on défend en cavalier et j'imagine que
j'imagine que
Laurent va vouloir peut-être
bouger sa cavalière ces trois
est-ce que c'est possible de faire un
truc du style cavalier de cavaliers G3
plus tard pour remplacer le cavalier et
essayer de proposer un échange de fou
sachant que le fou des deux c'est en
théorie le mauvais fou des blancs alors
pourquoi m'avez-vous parce que les pions
sont sur case noire donc le foie du mal
à passer et c'est pour ça que ce fou
dans la théorie c'est le mauvais fou
alors que le bon fou c'est le fou qui a
la couleur inverse des pions du centre
c'est pareil ici vous avez des pions sur
cases blanches donc le bon fou serait le
fou B4 et le mauvais serait le fou c'est
8 dans la théorie
après vous avez la théorie du mauvais
fou mais si le fou il passe de l'autre
côté de la structure et ben il pourrait
être pas mal du tout donc dans cette
position le foie du mal à passer au delà
de la structure donc c'est pour ça que
peut-être une idée à la cavalier de
derrière pour être assez intéressantes
pour échanger les pièces
je pense c'est cool pour les spectateurs
de pouvoir voir pour pouvoir voir les
joueurs souvent on voit des gaffes
souvent on voit des choses des mimiques
tout ça et je pense que c'est cool quand
même de voir les caméras en tout cas je
pense qu'il y a un gros plus le fait de
voir les caméras parce que vous en
pensez dans le chat
est-ce que vous aimez généralement voir
les caméras ou ou est-ce que vous
préférez est-ce que vous en foutez ou
est-ce que où est-ce que auprès de
parler voir moi je trouve ça je trouve
ça cool là au moins on voit quelqu'un
d'un côté humain quand on va les caméras
c'est pas deux joueurs vont leur
ordinateur et on voit rien
mais
ouais non mais et en plus en plus le
fait de mettre les caméras c'est aussi
un système aussi en tee-triche vous
savez que sur Internet on a très
facilement accès à des appareils
électroniques et du coup il y a une
caméra devant enfin sur eux qui nous est
partagé et il y a aussi des caméras qui
sont placées derrière eux en fait on
voit tout leur espace c'est comme si
c'est une caméra derrière moi qui qui me
filmait de dos pour voir ce que je fais
avec mes mains avec mon bureau etc pour
être sûr que je ne je ne triche pas donc
bon c'est des mesures en vitrines vous
savez que même si un tricheur retrait il
peut toujours essayer de passer outre et
de trouver un moyen de le faire mais bon
c'est plus dysphasif qu'autre chose dans
tous les cas à ma faute ça coule qui est
des caméras parce que en plus il y a
plein de joueurs dans le chat qui
connaissent pas qui connaissent pas les
joueurs et il y a Kubo F je pense que
dans le chat
il n'a pas la moitié qui connaissent
et moi je connais parce que je me tiens
je me tiens au courant des échecs du de
l'actualité et je sais que bah il a
gagné la zone empiades avec l'équipe
d'Ouzbékistan c'est un jeune en
progression et j'ai pas encore le chat
la plaque qui connaissent pas Laurent
vous le connaissez parce que il est
sorti ce com il a une très très grande
carrière d'échec il avait mangé 24 tout
ça bon Laurent il est hyper connu mais
il y a plein de joueurs que vous ne
connaissez pas donc je trouve que c'est
cool de manière générale de de mettre
les caméras de découvrir des joueurs de
voir un peu leur mimi d'avoir un peu
comment ils sont comment ils jouent et
puis et puis en fait tout ça quoi
une question comment parler dans le chat
sans se faire banal
ben écoute c'est un petit peu compliqué
mais en fait
[Musique]
apparemment bon tu as dû voir ce qui
s'est passé dernièrement avec
tscom et tout ça et ben
ils ont signé la paix en gros donc
maintenant on va essayer de plus en
parler de cette histoire en tout cas sur
tscom tu vas encore penser que qu'on ait
un chat difficile sur xoslo mais on a eu
des consignes de ne plus parler de
l'affaire de triche et
et
moi je trouve que alors une ronde j'en
sais rien tu sais pas ce qui s'est dit
etc mais bon après au final bon
mais ça c'est ça c'est des histoires un
peu
tu vois mais du coup bon on a eu on a eu
comme consigne de ne pas faire
de comment dire
de ne plus
en parler et
non mais c'est une histoire qui est
terminée il y a eu des accusations à
l'époque etc qui n'ont pas été prouvé
que si que ça voilà et maintenant que
l'histoire et ben elle était terminée et
ben pour le bien de
l'accuser et ben c'est mieux de ne plus
de ne plus en parler peu importe les
opinions que chacun
puisse avoir
c'est juste comme ça encore une fois
c'est un peu politique
et puis voilà je suis pas sur mon je
suis pas sur mon stream à moi donc je
peux pas vous exposer mon point de vue
comme je le voudrais mais si vous voulez
on en parlera sur mon stream sans aucun
souci et sans tabou ça il y aura pas de
problème mais ici vous comprenez bien
que j'ai pas tous les droits
mais j'ai des caméras voilà j'ai pas
tous les droits mais j'ai des caméras et
j'ai la caméra d'ailleurs de Laurent
Freyssinet qui loue cette partie donc là
il y a eu B3 V5 et donc le pion passé
dont je vous ai parlé dès le début de
partie et va a été créé par par yakubo F
je pense pas que ce soit le titre de jeu
d'échec qui
me fasse gagner ou pas la parole mais
bon
j'ai vu ça ce mec salut à toi salut
Domia à quelle heure ça joue en fait
c'est simple il y a pas d'heure ça joue
après la division 1 des perdants donc il
y a il y a deux matchs de partie avec
éventuellement Armageddon donc ça joue
un peu comme comme celui-là donc je
dirais d'environ une heure une heure et
demie mais j'ai pas d'heure précise ça
dépend vraiment de de
la durée des parties il y a des partis
qui peuvent être plus longues que
d'autres et surtout il peut y avoir des
armagasons donc il perd une partie en
plus je peux pas vous dire une heure
mais environ une heure une heure une
heure et demie facile
voilà pour la partie de firon 41 enfin
le match et ça va être bien sympa
alors à 4
c'est logique de la part de Laurent
Laurent qui essaye de casser un petit
peu
toute la structure des noirs pour
l'affaiblir et plus tard on peut
imaginer que des pions ici pour être
échangés voilà on peut imaginer qu'on
peut qu'on puisse tout prendre comme ça
et avant une structure ou au final et
ben
les Noirs vont avoir un pion passé 4 qui
est bloqué par une pièce en C3 mais plus
tard les blancs le plan général c'est à
dire F3 E4 pour casser un peu tout au
centre et éventuellement croquer le pion
en C4 donc là c'est vraiment les
pollutions qui sont assez connues ou les
Noirs ont pu passer protégés contre une
majorité au centre des blancs donc c'est
position que sont quand même assez
standard tout ça
c'est quand le match c'est une blague
trois questions au bout d'une minute
quand ça sera terminé dans une heure
environ
je veux plus répondre je crois
j'ai répondu à la question je pense
trois fois en
une minute
ouais je pourrais mettre un message
épinglé mais je sais pas comment on fait
malheureusement je suis pas très très
doué avec ça et que Yumi aujourd'hui
t'as pas eu envie de se lever mais du
coup ce que s'il y avait un modo ici qui
pourrait me le faire je serais bien
content mais je ne sais pas comment
faire
je sais pas comment faire pour épingler
un message peut-être que vous vous savez
ah il faut qu'il y ait ah il faut que le
message soit écrit sur le chat
je crois que j'ai compris que mon
comment on fait
alors je vais l'écrire
je vais écrire
hop là et je vais faire épingler mon
message j'arrive pas à le faire
le temps je vais mettre une heure c'est
quoi
mettre une heure
comme ça on voit pas me m'embêter
il veut pas mettre plus d'une demi-heure
bon je crois que c'est ça
ok on verra en tout cas
ça les maigrir bravo à toi et salut
Yosaku
salut que ça
c'est pas anglais
c'est après cette partie ça fait ce
match après ce match
après ce matin on a aussi en parallèle
on a été une bakrout qui joue on peut
aller voir sa partie aussi de temps en
temps mais par contre je n'ai pas du
tout de je n'ai pas sa caméra vous savez
que j'ai une caméra par division et ils
sont pas dans la même division
malheureusement mais
j'ai la partie si vous voulez on peut
aussi avoir
si vous voulez la voir on pourrait la
voir facilement il a les blancs ici
les blancs contre André Kim un breaking
qui est très solide et très très bon en
bleu de thérapie
alors donc tout bien a été joué donc là
il peut y avoir des menaces de
découverte du style puis on prend
puis on prend et pour prendre des cadres
vous voyez juste avant imaginons un truc
comme ça on aurait pu probablement faire
un truc peut-être de style là vous voyez
et après à Tourcoing ici j'ai une
découverte sur le cavalier qui aurait pu
être possible donc là je le fais dans ce
sens là mais peut-être que j'aurais pu
faire dans un autre sens là je sais pas
que cavalier bouge suivi de ton grand D4
qui avait le 4 par exemple ici et quand
on prend je prends ici vous voyez là je
gagne la paire de fou le fout de case
noir qui est important donc c'est pas de
pas mal et c'est pour ça ici que il
avait tombé un ici Laurent enfin une
menace comme ça il y a une petite dame
des 6 pour qu'il va défendre le fou en
B4 donc
Laurent qui a pour l'instant une bonne
avance au temps aussi il faut le dire
c'est important le temps dans ces
positions avec un crémant
du quasi Blitz
donc voilà
Dame des 6 comment est-ce qu'on peut
jouer ici je pense que ça va être un
coup comme il va falloir jouer un jour
c'est un petit il y a un visa à vie avec
les tours qui est intéressant là et
peut-être prises et essayer de faire
alors je suis pas sûr de faire F3 parce
que 3 pour l'instant ça menace pas
forcément
pas forcément E4 vous voyez que le 4
c'est une idée que j'aimerais bien avoir
sur le long terme en fait mais j'ai peur
qu'un jour j'ai aussi l'option de B4 qui
deviennent faibles quand je joue au Cap
donc il a fait dame là voilà on voit
vraiment bien
Laurent qui veut mettre la pression sur
la pièce en B4 il faut prendre ces trois
faut prendre ces trois et là on gagne la
paire de fou et les cases noires donc
intéressant en tout cas le choix de de
Laurent qui en plus en pratique je
trouve et ben pose des problèmes vous
voyez là il faut quand même calculer
tout un tas de coups comme du cavalier
B5 avec tout reprendre il faut calculer
il y a aussi du cavalier pandessin du
cavaluer 4 même tour promet 4 il y a
plein de choses qu'il faut calculer et
du coup c'est un coincé pratique ça
coûte c'est un très bon coup c'est un
coup solide en plus qui fait des menaces
donc je trouve que c'est un coup
excellent et une fois F5 pour échanger
son le bon fou de Laurent ici
donc est-ce que je peux manger en F5
j'aimerais bien avoir un truc ce style
là ça ça et une découverte mais je suis
pas sûr d'avoir
[Musique]
un truc sur le foot B4
par exemple ça ça va et vous
genre ça et ça
tant qu'à faire et si les Noirs ont
réussi à s'emparer du bon fou des blancs
et donc ici réussir à
échanger maintenant le mauvais fou
des blancs ça quand même pas mal aussi
en Caval et des 5 ici sur mon faut
prendre des deux je pense qu'elle va les
prendre ici il faut croire là et là
avoir si je prends là si je prends là si
je prends là si je prends là je sais pas
il y a trop de pièces en prise
en tout cas j'aime bien le coup faut F5
je trouve que c'est un bon coup il boit
du coca je crois ouais
je crois qu'il boit du coca
et voyez c'est pas de caméra et bah tu
saurais pas qu'il boit les coca et je
pense que c'est comme un élément
important celui que tu vois
sans caméra tu l'aurais jamais su
alors que là tu le sais
et donc attention Laurent qui s'arrache
les cheveux
et
qui se fait rattraper autant aussi
donc ce coup faut F5 qui est en fait
assez bien joué par par ce joueur ouzbek
qui va venir grignoter le le bon fou des
blancs de Laurent là c'est un paralle si
je bouge mon fou je perds à tomber donc
priori l'échange est obligatoire
ça risque d'être la suite jouée par les
noirs et ensuite voir ce qu'il y a pas
un moyen de faire un truc on peut
regarder ça c'est
si tu prends là je prends là une qualité
ça c'est impossible
sur cavalier B5 soit et là donc les
noirs sont obligés de faire ça prend les
deux et après il faut prendre les deux
je peux pas manger ici si je peux manger
ici en fait je pensais pas en prise donc
je pourrais manger là et juste dire que
j'ai une position ok mais en fait les
noirs avec ce pion passé protégé il me
faut un petit peu peur plus tard il peut
y avoir des trucs comme ça bien sûr je
bougerai dame avant
mais je peux aussi manger ici et voir si
je calcule
un truc qui pourrait marcher avec ce
pion passé protégé je pense que les
blancs doivent essayer de garder un
petit peu les pièces je pense que le
fait de trop échanger peu un peu les
condamner vous voyez avec ce pion qui
calme assez assez embêtant un truc comme
ça et je sais pas peut-être un G6 ça
c'est le cavalier avoir une case pour le
roi je vais C3 ramener la tour le
cavalier et j'ai vraiment ce petit pion
peut peut être dangereux donc j'ai
l'impression que
on peut échanger des pièces mais pas
toutes et je suis pas sûr que tout est
changé soit bénéfique pour pour Laurent
Laurent qui passe beaucoup beaucoup de
temps à réfléchir ici et qui a vraiment
tout reprend des quatre
grands sacrifié la qualité alors ça on
n'a pas du tout pensé alors là il y a
deux coups pour pour le noir soit tu
manges ces deux et chacun a mangé le
mauvais fou enfin le bon fou de
l'adversaire donc soit tu manges là
soit tu manges ici et tu manges là là il
faut il faut faire attention
parce que quand on prend des quatre je
pense que je peux manger ici
8 cabane le 4 je crois que c'est ça le
roulement
et le pire c'est quand tu prends là je
prends avec enfilade
donc donc c'est intéressant et ici
tout reprend B4 je pense qu'il faut
prendre ces deux va être le bon coup
c'est le coup qui a été joué assez vite
et après tout reprend B8 est au franc B8
F3 logique par G3 et H4 et aussi on
prépare aussi une plus tard la pousser
la pousser le 4 et voici le autre idée
[Musique]
je pense que l'idée de faire ça et ça il
y a des comme ça et écoutez je commence
à bien aimer les Noirs malheureusement
j'aime bien les Noirs je trouve que la
position elle est assez cool exception
passée protégée les colonnes ouvertes et
là on patauge un petit peu avec la dame
et la tour je sais pas ce qui va nous
faire Laurent
[Musique]
dans le chat de la de la de la position
moi j'aime bien la position des noirs
si je pouvais choisir je prendrai les
noirs
mais
[Musique]
compliqué
exception passé la tour qui peut rentrer
et ce four puisqu'il est pas très très
bon alors ce fond de il peut être bon si
un jour j'arrive à jouer 4 ou j'ai 5
mais c'est pas c'est pas dit que
j'arrive à jouer E4 parce que souvent
bah j'ai le pire en prise en décape qui
peut souffrir et qui peut être perdu
donc c'est vraiment pas évident il a
joué cavalué 8 donc j'aime bien il me
l'assel 6 il veut chasser le cavalier de
Laurent donc c'est un coup qui a l'air à
assez assez sympa
et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va jouer
c'est pas trop Laurent un peu déprimé
sur la caméra
salut Michel
et je sais pas comment est-ce qu'on va
continuer ici cette dame C1
j'ai proposé pour attaquer le fou et
menacer sortir de fou par E1 G3
peut-être que j'arriverai à
m'organiser un petit peu
ta classe est-ce que vous voulez voir
rapidement
qu'on passe sur sur Etienne Bacro alors
vous savez j'ai pas la caméra sur
Étienne
donc je vais essayer de trouver
je vais essayer de trouver
[Musique]
attendez
comment je fais
je vais essayer de trouver Étienne
il est ici
il a les il a les blancs
et après on va revenir dessus mais c'est
pas la caméra malheureusement sur sur
Étienne il a les il a les les blancs et
la 4 minutes 30 contre 20 minutes entre
20 et 20 20 secondes ça
20 secondes en face pas beaucoup
position elle est très compliquée la
position
mais peu de temps en face ça peut bien
marcher pour Étienne on va revenir sur
Laurent parce que on a la caméra
vraiment bien sur plutôt celle là ok il
faut F5 le Fou est venu en E1 il y a eu
ton B3
mais je garde vraiment les deux parties
ouvertes pour suivre on ira voir aussi
ce qui se passe dans la dans la première
division aussi mais ça on verra plus je
pense à la pause
et voilà on tourne B3 avec les jouets
il est un peu embêtant quand même mais
ok bon après il y a d'autres parties
mais c'est vrai que ça serait pas une
mauvaise nouvelle que Laurent arrive à
notre Alizée
lors de cette première partie parce que
je n'aime pas trop trop j'ai
l'impression que ça se dégrade un petit
peu vous voyez dans B4 le petit pion qui
est lancé ça c'est une proposition de
nulle implicite Dame des six fouger 3 ça
a répété et ça fera nul et
donc il répète bien évidemment
et maintenant c'est les noirs qui se
posent la question est-ce que on joue ou
pas il y a quand même mieux avec les
mains
salut mais oui j'ai aimé les caméras je
me suis
je me suis
préparé plutôt aujourd'hui j'ai pas la
caméra sur une Bacro par contre c'est
c'est les caméras c'est divisions par
division et je peux avoir toutes les
caméras de la division 2 si vous voulez
mais je peux pas avoir une caméra de la
Division 1 Une de La 2 une de la 3 en
même temps ça ne marche pas comme ça ils
ont plusieurs romans en même temps
donc j'ai pas ça
c'est une bague
Laurent est en avance et puis finalement
c'est pas clair il veut jouer avec les
Noirs mais la raison la position est la
meilleure pour lui elle s'est bien passé
il peut jamais être moins bien
donc il y a pas eu de il y a pas eu de
[Musique]
il y a pas eu de
répétition
alors dame Davis
comment est-ce qu'on joue il y a un
cavalier à 4 cavaliers c'est 5 qui me
plaît bien mais j'ai un peu peur
siphon qui me fait peur depuis le début
je vous le dis
question qui me fait peur depuis le
début
est-ce que le 4 c'est un coup non il y a
plus on prend des 4 c'est pas du tout un
coup E4 si j'arrivais à un jeu de
tourner
le 4 mais bon je risque d'avoir un
problème quand même sur le long terme
sur ma structure d'option et sur mon roi
aussi
voilà un peu ce qui va se passer
alors
ok F6 le Caval qui va déménager j'ai que
la case G4 est-ce que ici vous prend les
quatre c'est un coup
possible
parce que du coup
on a les coups d'Étienne Bacro et on a
l'impression que ça joue ici alors faut
prendre un temps intéressant parce que
la case 4 maintenant peut être
intéressant de votre ça a été fait et un
jour si les mêmes arrivent à mettre un
cavalier ici et elle changeait lui et
ben je peux avoir un super cavalier en
carte contre le mauvais fou donc et
manger là ça risque de grossi les cases
noires je suis pas sûr qu'elle change
sans favorable pour les blancs
mais c'est pas comment on continue ici
c'est des problèmes quand même madame
qui bougent pas trop à cause du cavalier
trop bien je pense douchera rien il y a
ce pion qui pourrait être passé la
position avec un difficile pour les
noirs
pour les blancs excusez-moi des fois je
me trompe de couleur je veux dire
mais
[Musique]
je trouve qu'il y a un problème
alors celui que
avec ces petites
comment dire
équations
damassis
OK
mais bon 4 il est 7 mois de casser lui
pour manger là les problèmes c'est que
oui
[Musique]
donc là il y a plus de temps la pendule
40 secondes contre 15 c'est la chance de
Laurent faut que Laurent en profite du
diagnotte pour mettre la pression sur le
joueur ouzbek la cavalier 6 il y a eu un
rêve 7 d'abord on va essayer de mettre
le roi un petit peu en sécurité G5
peut-être manger un jour ramener la tour
en F1 il faut ramener la dame sûrement à
3 ça a l'air pas mal entre quand même
des cases et tour B3 il va revenir ici
je pense que Laurent a tout ok pour
faire un nul la position est toujours
difficile pour pour
les blancs
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ici moi j'aime bien
la prise
il y a eu
prise tout reprend ou puis on prend
pour qu'on fait attention au roi quand
même et puis on prend OK
il veut le solide surprise
pas évident
la roche est un coup aussi je peux
donner le pion des fois pour essayer de
m'activer et à trois cartes qui va
arriver j'ai peur pour ce pion en D4 la
meuf-2 Toro 4 tourner un C3
j'ai l'impression quand même que les que
les Noirs avancent et
j'ai du mal à bouger mes pièces c'est
trop apparemment est une faute il y
avait mieux que ça
ça coûte tout fin aussi donc vous
imaginez bien que les coudes touffe
c'est pas les meilleurs j'ai trois
ça va très vite un jour plus de temps et
la pollution est extrêmement compliqué
donc d'habitude qui bloque le pion
maintenant inscrit un moyen de faire
tourner trop et de manger ici c'est
chaud donc on écarte on prend C3 le roi
blanc est complètement ouvert mais
attention que j'ai dû contrôler avec ton
C7 oulala grosse erreur grosse erreur je
crois de du joueur avec les Noirs
apparemment Adam prend été une grosse
faute bon ça va très vite encore une
fois apparemment je crois que roi H2
devait gagner la partie et un pion de
plus quand même pour pour Laurent qui va
essayer de gagner la partie la plus de
temps il a un pion de plus c'est une
flamme donc c'est avantage blanc bien
sûr mais il y a quand même pas mal de
réseau de perpétuel donc il faut faire
vachement attention ici
avec avec les blancs comme H4 un jour
mettre le roi caché un peu le roi par
ici
si on prend la je prends H7
donc il y a un pion de moins
c'est je pense la position qui doit être
nul mais ok il peut il peut la jouer
ouais apparemment il était gagnant
complètement
Laurent mais c'était très très complexe
on ira voir ça après
et on va rapidement cette partie elle va
durer encore longtemps parce qu'il va
tenter de la gagner pendant un moment
donc je vous propose d'aller voir
rapidement Laurent Laurent qui a perdu
malheureusement qui s'est mater mater de
l'escalier par par André Kin donc
Étienne qui aura droit à la revanche
tout à l'heure
contre
André Kin et en cas de non-victoire de
d'Étienne et ben il sera éliminé de la
compétition qui est là division 3 du
championnat de testo Laurent il est en
Division 2
dame aussi ça a été joué par le noir
plus le pion c'est une série qui est nul
mais en pratique toujours y avoir des
erreurs la tête G5 jouer il passe commit
pour l'instant
nul signé ouais les joueurs sont partis
et nous on a un petit délai vous savez
qu'on a une minute de
délai entre les entre les caméras et
et la partie
voilà la nul a été signée par les
joueurs donc ok une belle nulle de quand
même de Laurent qui a bien tenu là une
position difficile et rapidement alors
il y a eu un karaté par Laurent
apparemment déjà ici j'ai trois c'est
une grosse erreur à cause de dame 6
qui menace pour eux
en force ça a l'air pas mal du tout et
apparemment c'était c'était
difficile et sur dame c'est 6 dames
c'est 2 et dams C4 trop Detroit et
apparemment le seul coup ici pour tenir
cette tournoi échec alors c'est
incroyable donc
je prends là et puis j'ai encore des
menaces avec le passé etc mais bon ok et
à la place il y a juste pour prendre des
quatre qui est une très grosse faute
voilà jauge qui monte tout en haut et là
sur tout recommencer 3
c'est la partie et là il y a eu d'un 31
et rentrer dans la finale avec qui en
plus qui n'est pas gagnant et ici
j'ai pas du tout ce qui s'est passé dans
le chat ah c'est les majuscules c'est le
c'est le banoto de
quand on écrit avec trop de majuscules
alors que tu avais écrit mais
[Musique]
ok donc là apparemment le coup gagnant
c'était roi H2
donc
tu as ça en prise
et en plus j'ai tout qui arrive
si tu pars pour défendre la tour comme
par exemple
de partout là c'est maths
c'est mat
incroyable
incroyable et terre raté par Laurent
mais bon ok les joueurs avaient plus
tant la pendule on le rend avait quand
même ici 10 secondes donc c'est vrai que
cette trouvable mais je pense que
Laurent il a vu cette finale il s'est
dit bon j'ai pris en plus et c'est sûr
que la terre pas et quand tu es et quand
tu es enfin il est en souffrance pendant
toute la partie je pense que c'était
peut-être une une bonne
comment dire solution de jeu celle-là
alors les joueurs ont l'air de avoir
repris un serpent cash
ça reprend cash
ou changer la la fenêtre on garde les
bonnes couleurs ça implique à changer
dans la division 1 il y a toujours 10
minutes de pause par contre la division
2 et 3 il y a pas de pause vous démerdez
vous jouez vite comme ça on parle plus
assez marrant je vais voir si Étienne a
repris aussi du coup je pense que tienne
ou non
a perdu ici avec les noirs
qui s'est passé
what
ah oui
c'est pas c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est
une blague ou
c'est une blague ou quoi Etienne qui
joue à 5 à 4
ah ouais je crois qu'il a quitté complet
je crois qu'il a filté complet on va
rapidement
rapidement ça c'est la partie de Étienne
Macron contre André Kim la première
voir un peu ce qui s'est passé pour
qu'il
comme ça
il y a eu un truc qui s'est passé
il faut les choses un peu
ah oui
F3
x 6
ok non juste en fait je pense qu'il
était tilté ok donc Étienne c'est
terminé malheureusement
et donc sur le rang Laurent qui est le
Nord je peux tourner le chéquier
malheureusement chez qui
la caméra alors je pourrais vous le
tourner en fait si vous voulez
garder on va faire un truc
je vais vous faire ça
que vous tournez les chéquier
et voilà par contre le temps là vous
voyez que le temps il est sur noir sur
blanc mais
mais bon c'est c'est comme ça
on peut pas faire mieux par contre pour
le temps
pas le changer
et non normalement c'est pas fait pour
changer
tourne l'écran
et je vais mettre à jour le score quand
même
pour pas qu'on me demande à chaque fois
c'est quoi ce soir
toutes les trois secondes
le score ici
et donc Laurent avec les Noirs donc là
c'est la fameuse
ouverture
berlinoise
donc ça c'est une ouverture c'est une
mine de l'Espagnol qui est réputé pour
être extrêmement extrêmement solide pour
les noirs et c'est cramique d'ailleurs
en
2000 qui avait popularité aussi cette
ligne avec les avec les noirs et ça a
l'air bizarre parce qu'on perd plein de
temps au début avec le roi on se dit ok
etc donc cavalier qui va en tous les
sens mais au final c'est extrêmement
solide donc la structurellement parlant
vous voyez qu'il y a quatre pions ici
contre 3
et de l'autre côté j'ai quatre contre
trois étaient blancs et généralement
c'est une nanas sont bonnes pour les
blancs parce que cette majorité au
centre en fait ce qu'il faut comprendre
dans cette structure d'option c'est que
si jamais j'ai changé toutes les pièces
mais je dis bien toutes les pièces si on
avait cette position là sans aucune
pièce avec une tour de changer les
cavaliers les fous échangés et bien au
final gagnerait pour les blancs pourquoi
parce qu'en fait les Blancs ont majorité
en cas de contrôle ici donc ils vont
amener le roi E4 ils vont jouer F4 G4
ils vont pousser des pions et se créer
un pion passé de ce côté là alors que de
l'autre côté les noirs et ben ils vont
eux aussi essayer de se créer un peu
Basset de l'autre côté mais en fait
juste pour vous dire un truc il y a
plusieurs manières de t'empêcher la
création d'un club passé quand les trois
contre quatre comme ça et une des
manières d'empêcher la création de
repasser si le jeu par exemple comme ça
[Musique]
jamais jamais se créer un pion passé par
exemple sur B5 et ben je touche à rien
si tu prends je prends bah tu as deux
pions c'est contre un pion tu passeras
pas et à quoi ah ça passe pas c'est
toujours pas
B5 toujours quoi c'est 5 c'est 4 ok
voilà je vais quand même finir à manger
quand même je pense
mais en fait tu pourras pas te créer le
passé c'est impossible je peux aussi
faire celui-là donc C4 B3 à 2 cette
structure là tu passes jamais avec ton
cas de contrôle et je peux aussi faire
un C4 B3 A4 toutes ces manœuvres étaient
blancs font que les les noirs peuvent
jamais passer sur un coup comme pompe
assise B5 je touche à rien et quand tu
manges je mange
tu manges je mange au final tu as deux
points doublés qui servent à rien de
stratégie sur le long terme pour les
blancs ça pourrait échanger absolument
toutes les pièces pour rentrer dans
cette finale qui est gagnante pour les
blancs le problème c'est que bien
entendu les noirs avec affaires les
Noirs ils savent très très bien tout ça
et ils vont jamais changer toutes les
pièces ils vont toujours rester avec une
pièce ou deux pour être sûr que c'est
final n'est pas lieu quoi vous voyez et
donc du coup c'est c'est la stratégie un
petit peu qu'on pourrait avoir dans ces
positions
alors j'ai pas encore ouvert le chat de
Youtube je veux le faire de suite
je sais pas si on a eu des gens sur le
chat
et on a eu et on a eu des commentaires
donc salut à toi Jérémy salut à toi y
aico
je viens d'apparaître sur le chat de
YouTube j'avais oublié de l'ouvrir
j'ai deux chats en même temps j'ai
twitch et j'ai et j'ai YouTube
donc voilà en tout cas si vous avez des
questions par rapport à une partie par
rapport à une position par rapport à
quoi que ce soit n'hésitez pas à me
solliciter
sur le chat vous savez ça répond toutes
les questions pertinentes
et
voilà est-ce que quelqu'un peut me dire
c'est compliqué de créer une chaîne sur
YouTube ou twitch non c'est assez c'est
assez facile Michel
alors déjà une chaîne twitch en fait ce
qui est marrant c'est que sans le savoir
il fait et ben tu as une chaîne twitch
si tu veux tu peux stream aujourd'hui
maintenant tu peux tu as une chaîne et
YouTube tu te crées un compte et puis tu
fais une vidéo quoi
donc en fait
après il faut d'ailleurs se créer créer
du contenu ça sera autre chose mais
tu peux
enfin ton compte twitch il est créé
voilà il est créé
vous rappelez le niveau de notre jardin
on a deux notre gerbère on en a un c'est
à vous autov et qui joue dans la
division 1 et ça c'est yakubuer les deux
joueurs qui étaient qui sont bien d'or
médaillé d'or lors des Olympiades
2022 donc il y a beau F c'est un genre
qui est maintenant il a environ 26 50
feed donc c'est c'est un excellent
niveau il est jeune donc je sais pas
quel âge il a avoir environ 18 ans un
truc du style et 26 50 et il fait que de
progresser donc c'est un joueur qui n'a
pas fini de progresser
donc c'est un jeune talent
là il est plus ou moins son max hello
mais il va continuer à monter en tout
cas
oui c'est très sérieux
dès que tu vois un bien ouzbek chinois
généralement c'est extrêmement sérieux
en face donc
B3 a été joué
moi j'avais vu une vidéo à la fois que
je croyais que c'était lui une vidéo où
il jouait au championnat du monde
au championnat du monde de Blitz ou
rapide un des deux il avait une position
complètement gagnante contre je crois
que c'était contre contre
guelfand qui était ancien vice champion
du monde contre allemande et il avait
pas gagné une finale avec trois pions de
plus
gagnant et il avait tilté
complètement gagnante et il a pas gagné
et il était en colère et il y avait la
vidéo sur Youtube c'était
un peu mal au cœur en vrai de voir ça
s'il y a trois égalités
les Noirs passeront en fait je
t'explique il y a deux parties là on est
dans les phases des de la deuxième
division donc il y a deux parents
[Musique]
allô allô ouais j'ai repris alors je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé j'ai
absolument pas touché à mon micro
et mon micro c'est éteint tout seul
alors je pense que je comprends
maintenant d'où vient le problème parce
qu'en fait j'avais un problème similaire
avec mon ancien micro et en fait je
l'habitude de brancher
le micro sur un
USB en particulier
et en fait je crois que c'est mon USB
qui marche pas bien parce que j'ai
racheté un micro quand même
marchait plus
et j'ai même problème avec l'autre micro
donc c'est pas un problème de micro
c'est un problème du SB j'aurais
peut-être pu essayer d'autres d'autres
prises USB avant de racheter un micro
donc ça m'apprendra
dans les deux j'en ai un de voyage on va
dire et c'est parce que je disais du
coup parler de quoi alors je parlais
d'une vidéo que j'avais vu sur Youtube
de Yakubu bref qui avait perdu sa partie
et qui avait le cœur complètement brisé
tu es parti en larmes et ouais tu joues
une partie
importante contre
un des top joueur tu es complètement
gagnant et tu gagnes pas c'est dur
ton colorant qui pousse le pion a en
espérant
ouvrir la colonne pour la tour donc vous
voyez que les blancs en plus d'espace au
centre
il y a des cas où on peut jouer du G4
pour essayer d'acheter cette cavalier et
en fait c'est très solide pour les noirs
parce que ma structure en fait de pion
doublée mais la structure de pion et ben
si vous voulez le contrôle plein de
cases qui sont pas atteignables du coup
par les Blancs
et en plus j'ai la paire de fou j'ai la
paire de fou une structure très solide
mais j'ai toujours ce problème vous avez
ce problème de de majorité au centre
pour les blancs qui fait un peu la
différence des fois
donc et aussi d'espace donc le blanc
plus d'espace et on majorité au centre
qui font quand même que normalement
c'est légère avantage blanc mais il y a
la part de vous chez les Noirs assez
intéressante et voilà mais si jamais
j'arrive à manœuvrer avec les Noirs
comme ça et ben la pollution elle est
pas si mal pour les noirs
alors Laurent Freyssinet il est en
looser bracket de la division 2 c'est ça
il a perdu un match hier
Freyssinet Laurent il a perdu contre
Artémis artemief un gros gros client
aussi en blitz donc il a battu de raief
dans le premier match donc ensuite au
deuxième tour il a perdu contre Artémis
et maintenant il se retrouve en barrette
des losers et pour le deuxième tour et
il affronte il y a que bref
[Musique]
non je pense pas
super GM devant en fait moi je pense
peut-être que la fille de devrait créer
un titre de super GM pour les joueurs à
plus de 2750 ou plus de 200700 un truc
comme ça donc
je pense que c'est
ce que la fibre de faire pour
différencier je savais que vous vous
voyez un grand maître qui a 2400 hello
et comparer ça avec avec quinzaine ben
il y a 500 points de dégâts
[Musique]
et pourtant ils sont quand même tous les
deux donc je pense que c'est vrai que
il y a une différence de niveau entre un
GM lambda et un GM et un top GM mais
sinon à part ça je pense pas que un
prestige de perdu par rapport à non je
pense que
je pense pas maintenant il y a quand
même plus de monde donc c'est plus
facile je pense de devenir grand maître
par rapport à l'époque mais ça reste
quand même prestigieux ça reste quand
même quelque chose de difficile à
atteindre et voilà donc je pense pas que
ce soit devenu moins précis je vais
avoir
je pense que c'est quand même toujours
aussi toujours aussi importante toujours
aussi cool
mais je suis pour créer un titre
supplémentaire pour les tops GMA ça fait
longtemps que comment on parle et un
titre pour le top GMS c'est vraiment
sympa
super ou top GM enfin peu importe le nom
que tu que tu mets
[Musique]
ce serait
ça serait ça serait bien
Caron fille rouge j'ai des questions sur
YouTube sur
twitch ça jouera après le match de
l'Euro
voilà
après le match de Laurent d'ailleurs
j'ai pas suivi les résultats de
la première division je vais vous le
dire de suite
dire tout de suite
que s'est-il passé le premier match on a
Wesley Sow qui a fait nul en 100 coups
contre laser
et deuxième partie c'est Caruana qui a
battu en 19 coups
c'est quand même
quand même assez incroyable à ce niveau
là et après trois
[Musique]
il nous a habitué à mieux quand même
dernièrement
donc pour l'instant Abdou il va
peut-être être éliminé de la compétition
et c'est des magical salut Cyril luxe
non c'est l'ours il était déjà là depuis
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
n'existe pas encore ils l'ont pas encore
enfin peut-être que ça va exister un
jour peut-être pas au n'en sais rien
mais
si ça arrive il y aura un système
un système pour pour le tenir peut-être
avec des normes peut-être avec je sais
pas moi mais il faudrait tout un système
je pense que ça pique montrer un petit
peu les choses
et je pense ça serait un peu intéressant
d'avoir ça et des grands maîtres dans le
monde échec aujourd'hui doit y avoir
environ je crois que c'était 1000
combien
1300 actifs je crois les remettre
quand tu es aimé trouver tournoi oui
c'est clair quand tu es ami tu dois
trouver des grands maîtres pour faire
des armes contre eux il y en a pas
toujours tout le temps donc
mais il y a des joueurs très très forts
qui sont Africains on a d'ailleurs le
numéro 1 africain c'est amine Bassem qui
qui joue pour l'Égypte si je dis pas de
bêtises et il a 2700 lois donc c'est pas
un peintre et
il est extrêmement fort et après tu en
as d'autres hein
tu as aussi t'avais Hicham Hamdouchi qui
maintenant je prends la France c'était
un grand maître marocain qui a eu plus
de 2600 yellows et après tu as Adly qui
aussi égyptien vélo tu as pas mal de
monde
voilà
super combattre non rien c'est en fait
on essayait de de trouver un titre pour
pour comparer un petit peu les
grammaires vous savez que là si on prend
un grand maître à 2400 hello et encore
mettre comme manus caractère
mais il y a une différence de ouf entre
entre deux joueurs donc créer un titre
supplémentaire comme le top GM comme
super GM ça pourrait être intéressant
mais c'est un débat depuis très
longtemps avec des instances etc on va
voir peut-être que un jour ça aura lieu
peut-être pas on n'en sait rien en tout
cas
voilà et votre recherche de titre de mi
et ben écoute ça y est on arrive ici tu
vois bien que à côté de mon nom il y a
un petit ami ça veut dire que j'ai enfin
réussi et pourtant ça fait des années et
des années que j'attendais ça que j'ai
essayé de de l'atteindre et c'est fait
c'est un débat du chat c'est un débat
que moi j'ai avec moi-même depuis depuis
très longtemps depuis plus de 10 ans
donc après je pense enfin je sais que ce
débat a déjà été fait avec d'autres gens
aussi je sais pas jusqu'où ça va
vraiment se débat mais c'est un débat
qui qui existe à peu près c'est pas
totalement c'est pas totalement
que moi quoi
et c'est vrai que c'est un débat que je
fais moi-même
et c'est vrai que oui je des fois je
parle tout seul et je et je me parle à
moi-même je fais un débat avec moi-même
ça
déjà beaucoup de monde qui quittent le
terme super génial oui parce que on
différencie un
2016 un mvl dans 2004 ou 2005 quoi on
dit sur Nancy c'est clair donc là on
voit qu'il y a marqué GM le Grand Frais
ciné GM bah ouais mais en fait tu
pourras un petit s devant quoi SGM ça
fait un peu
j'en sais rien moi j'en sais rien mais
c'est vrai que il y a une différence
quand même entre certains grands maîtres
et d'autres
c'est juste ça voilà
ouais alors super j'aime ceux qui sont
en Top 10
oui et non je pense pas que ça soit un
truc qui est où il y a que le hello
par exemple pour être maître ou grand
maître il faut le vélo mais aussi
d'énormes donc là du coup
je sais pas que le hello ça m'a l'air un
peu injuste enfin après bon c'est un
débat c'est pas moi qui fait les qui
fait les règles qui fait tout ça mais je
pense ça serait bien de changer un peu
les choses et ça pourrait motiver
certains joueurs qui se reposent un peu
sur leur laurier depuis un petit moment
et qui ne travaille pas forcément les
échecs et le fait de de
proposer un petit titre en plus pourrait
peut-être
motiver certains joueurs je sais pas
avoir
Etienne il a perdu
pour être un super GM
vieux niveau ouais
bah il y a eu des périodes où il y a eu
plusieurs 2008 maintenant il y en a
beaucoup moins
oui bon
à voir chaque enfin je sais pas on va
voir
moi non pas motivé porter de grand
maître c'est trop dur
c'est trop dur
j'ai envie de travailler pour l'avoir
c'est beaucoup de travail pour
finalement peu de reconnaissance
voilà mais non je ne oui après si je
suis pas loin je me répète la question
un jour mais là actuellement maintenant
je sais que je suis beaucoup trop loin
d'être passé grand maître donc pas du
tout un truc que
je fasse pas un objectif que je me que
je me mets voilà
donc crois c'est vide donc Laurent qui
joue qui joue vite et qui joue solide
mais c'est vrai que les blancs ils
poussent ils poussent ils poussent
le titre de GM bah quand est top 100
mondial tu es quand même parce que top
100 mondial c'est 26 50 à peu près donc
tes grands
donc c'est clair
ouais c'est possible que que bientôt et
bon raccourcissent les cadences
c'est possible avoir comment ça comment
ça se passe
salut François Jacques
alors cavalier
là
en fait à chaque fois que je joue pour
changer une pièce et ben il y a cette
finale pour toi parler tout à l'heure
avec avec cette majorité centrale pour
les blancs qui peut faire très mal donc
on a du mal vraiment à toutes les
changer et en plus c'est 4h5 ça arrive
et j'ai pas beaucoup de backup regardez
je peux pas trop reculer mon fou enfin
je pourrais que les monts fous mais bon
c'est dur hein
donc imagine qu'il veut essayer de
passer par là par là c'est de faire des
choses qu'avec les deux avec les jouets
on préparait F4 on va aussi faire E3 on
défend aussi la cadage 4 qui peut être
aussi une case intéressante pour pour
les Noirs un jour
en tout cas il faut que l'on continue à
jouer vite parce qu'il est pas bien dans
cette position il est assez mal et
[Musique]
si il devient mal au temps ça peut
devenir vraiment un problème
très mal je ne sais pas si c'est que moi
le son a l'air très faible est-ce qu'on
m'entend bien dans le chat ou est-ce que
c'est où est-ce que le problème vient de
chez moi dites-moi s'il vous plaît
nickel le son ici oui
monte le volume j'entends bien
nickel bah écoutez vous êtes
ça va ok ok bah écoute je pense que le
son vient de chez toi du coup
[Musique]
je sais pas si tu as
tu as un casque ou pas
le titre de quand il doit mettre
[Musique]
alors des fois ça dépend des ordinateurs
Valmy moi je sais que j'ai un ordinateur
portable à la maison avec lequel j'ai
beaucoup de mal j'ai beaucoup de mal à
regarder des films ou quoi ou parce que
le son est vraiment pourri quoi mais
après c'est un vrai PC ou quoi
normalement tu as des enceintes
normalement dans le son est censé être
ok ça dépend je pense de ton ordinateur
aussi
le titre de quand il va mettre
comment dire c'est pas un titre
international enfin si c'est un titre
reconnu par la fille mais c'est pas du
tout un titre
un titre qui sert à quelque chose dans
le sens où quand tu fais une norme de
merde par exemple il faut les cinq
titres et le titre de Maître enfin de
candidattre ne compte pas dans les
titrés genre je sais pas je joue quatre
grands mètres et 1 candidat mètres et
ben j'ai pas ma norme parce que il me
manquait
c'est un titre que eux ils décernent
mais c'est pas un titre pour eux donc ça
c'est bizarre donc il y a deux options
pour les pour les corianomètres en fait
il y a des gens qui aiment bien prendre
parce que ça fait un petit titre etc
donc c'est cool et il y a d'autres gens
qui le prennent aussi parce que
par rapport en fait c'est un titre
c'est un titre feed et moi j'avais connu
quelqu'un qui le prenait qu'il avait
pris parce que dans son entreprise où il
travaillait et ben il récompenser un
petit peu les sportifs de haut niveau en
leur donnant des fois des jours de
congés pour aller faire des tournois de
leur sport quoi donc lui quand il va
mettre 2200 et l'eau je vais juste
porter de haut niveau et du coup avec
son petit C de camp de diamètre et ben
il est arrivé à partir des fois en
vacances et avoir des jours de congés
payés par l'entreprise pour aller faire
ce petit tournoi bon bien sûr le mec
était pas du tout pro mais il avait des
gens de congés donc du coup du coup
dans ce cas de figure je veux bien
comprendre mais sinon c'est compliqué
et Laurent qui qui est très très mal le
pion qui est arrivé en aussi cela il y a
plus de temps pour les blancs
c'est un coup est-ce que ça c'est un
coup aussi mais là c'est maths c'était
pas clair
après j'ai beaucoup de problèmes avec
les avec les Noirs il y a pas beaucoup
de temps pour pour les blancs mais la
position qu'elle m'a assez facile à
jouer il y a pas il y a pas de problème
j'ai 5 questions il faut qu'on F6 et
j'ai pas de rupture de cavalier j'ai 6
peut être une idée mais bon
il faut vite en plus en face
que tu tranches sur apprendre simple et
sur et surtout à cette m'en fous
j'aurais plus jamais il y aura BK4 et
sur fou A5 je sais pas comment on va la
jouer mais
c'est
ce qu'il y a pas intérêt pour le 6
d'ailleurs qui passe un peu compliqué
il le fait maintenant alors ça par
contre je l'ai pas du tout vu prise faut
prendre et 7 tours c'est fort
il a fait à l'envers et puis on prend
fou prends un TAC la tour sur ton bouge
E7 et tour des 8 qui est maths imparable
très jolie de la part de
yakubuer qui va sortir le
probablement partir E7 je vois pas
comment tu empêches peut-être tu peux
gb6
j'ai encore je suis encore en vie je
crois
F4 F5 va arriver je quand même trois
pions passés avec
avec les Blancs c'est trop dur en plus
c'est des menaces de madré après le 7
fou c'est deux la tour qui va bouger
de la part de yakubuer
pas manger là parce que je suis matte du
couloir
comment ça se défend ça et peut-être
c'est pas l'astuce
est-ce que j'ai pas ça ça c'est
pour apprendre j'ai échec et ce qu'on a
il y a peut-être petit chose à faire
les GP5 Laurent
prise du
pion à 4
tours ici et maintenant bah écoute
Laurent qui Laurent qui s'en sort
Laurent qui va qui va peut-être gagner
la partie en fait Laurent qui a
complètement retourné son adversaire que
s'est-il passé il y a eu un betprint A4
j'aurais tempo qui a été un coup
horrible de la part de la part des
blancs et maintenant j'ai une pièce de
plus regardez bien j'ai une pièce de
plus j'ai un fou contre un pion
si nul rien dedans mais si il gagne il
avait encore plus loin
les joueurs sont partis on sait pas ce
qui s'est passé mais vu la tête de
yacouboueve je pense que Laurent a bien
gagné sa partie on va voir un peu ce qui
s'est passé
la tour qui va passer par là-bas je
pense que c'est maintenant pour
pour les noirs qui a complètement craqué
dans cette partie il avait hyper bien
joué
et il s'est fait il s'est fait avoir par
Laurent Laurence et l'expérience un
gamin c'est l'expérience Laurent
tous vos trois
fois cinq
comment ça termine
[Musique]
il y a une
ça a fait nul ok ça fait nul bon du coup
on sait pas jusqu'à qu'au dernier moment
Laurent à la fin il est il est gagnant
il est complètement gagnant et bon il
est revenu de loin donc c'est vrai qu'il
a pas beaucoup de pions mais il a une
pièce de plus et les pions sont sans
stopper donc malheureusement il n'a pas
assez de temps mais cette partie quand
même il doit la gagner l'ordinateur
l'ordinateur il donne il donne fou G4
et ce roi là il donne fou F2 il a réussi
à sortir
sans fou
en fait c'est gagnant facilement quand
même c'est gagnant facilement à la fin
mais en fait c'est un peu le même cas
que tout à l'heure vous voyez que
Laurent était malmené pendant toute la
partie et finalement la fin il a réussi
à avoir une position gagnante comme tout
à l'heure c'est même scénario et
finalement bah il a pris la nul c'est
déjà un pour résultat au vu de la partie
et donc voilà donc l'armée qui va
commencer dans quelques instants je vais
le surveiller rapidement ce qui s'est
passé à côté parce que du coup vous
savez que 45 va reprendre
va reprendre quand
les parties seront terminés la partie de
la division 1 sont terminées donc du
coup
j'ai pas envie d'être
alors ils ont son goût
et c'est le début de la partie donc
c'est bon je pense qu'on va pouvoir on
aura le temps de suivre la partie de
Laurent Freyssinet donc là je vous
rappelle que on est à 1 partout je vais
vous changer d'ailleurs le score on a un
et donc le score ici va se jouer
le score va se jouer ici
enfin la cadence va se jouer avec des
enchères ce qui veut dire en fait que
les deux joueurs vont envoyer à la vitre
le temps avec lequel ils sont prêts à
prendre les Noirs ça veut dire par
exemple
l'orage va être tiens moi je veux 9,50
si je vais les noirs et sur adversaire
il peut mettre je sais pas 9,27
et en fait le joueur qui radit le temps
le plus bas va gagner l'enchère et aura
les Noirs donc à quoi ça sert d'avoir
les Noirs dans les dans l'Armageddon bah
en fait c'est que tu peux juste deux
résultats ça veut dire par exemple si tu
fais match nul et que tu as les noirs et
bah tu qualifies automatiquement pour la
ronde d'après si tu as les blancs tu as
obligations de gagner donc en fait la
cadence ça va être 15 minutes pour les
blancs
avec obsing gagner et les Noirs ont
beaucoup moins de temps
mais ils peuvent faire mieux vous voyez
donc c'est intéressant et voilà donc je
sais pas ce que ce que va prendre
Laurent si tu veux si tu veux absolument
avoir les blancs bah tu mets 15 minutes
sur sur ton enchères
plus bas que toi mais
[Musique]
ce qu'il veut pas prendre les Noirs
aussi on va voir normalement j'ai le
temps
qui arrive
sur
[Musique]
ça mais je crois que j'aurais pas le
temps je suis pas sûr que les oreilles
parce qu'on est en Division 2
et dans la division 2 normalement il
marque pas les temps je crois
[Musique]
ok j'ai pas je crois que j'aurais pas le
temps mais ne vous inquiétez pas dès que
dès que
la partie se lance vous verrez
directement le temps des joueurs parce
que j'aime bien avoir aussi c'est avoir
le pari que les joueurs ont balancé pour
pour les couleurs c'est intéressant je
trouve de voir à quel point tu voulais
les noirs
par exemple hier on a vu c'était tabac
abeilles qui jouait contre lasavik et on
a vu que la zavik il a mis un truc du
style neuf 9 50 comme ça et tabataba il
a mis 14 50 donc ça va il voulait
absolument avoir les blancs
derrière en face ils mettent ils mettent
très bien plus enfin bien moins bac 14
50 donc voilà la partie de Laurent qui
va bientôt
apparaître on va pouvoir la suivre et
pendant ce temps là et ben dans le la
division 1 et bah ça joue encore je peux
vous dire un petit peu rapidement parce
que je vois
que la position d'azazate qui est saut
et ben elle est à peu près égale et ils
ont fait nul voilà
par contre Abdou
contre karwana
obligation de gagner cette partie sinon
il sera éliminé et j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a une pollution pas très bonne
notre ami Abdou voir un peu ce qui va se
passer après et on va voir à partir de
Laurent
Florent qui n'a pas encore débuté alors
je sais pas ce qu'ils font pour les
armagidants à ce qu'ils attendent que
tout soit terminé ou est-ce qu'ils
envoient directement tout à l'heure ça a
pas traîner tout à l'heure c'est vrai
que ça a envoyé ah c'est vite la partie
la revanche en tout cas
c'est pas du tout si
[Musique]
pas du tout là si ça va se lancer direct
ou pas
il mise il mise un temps
comme par exemple la photo noir moi je
compte toi moi je joue contre toi et je
sais que si jamais je prends les blancs
je peux absolument gagner et ces gilets
noirs et ben je peux me permettre de
faire ma tenue le pour me qualifier et
donc on va tous les deux proposer un
temps
un temps avec lequel on jouera avec les
noirs
et
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que le temps de plus bas
entre le tien et le mien aura les Noirs
donc si on les deux joueurs et qu'on
veut tous les deux baignoire
et ben je sais que tu vas prendre les
Noirs enfin je sais que tu veux
absolument les noirs et je sais que tu
sais que je vais prendre le noir
donc je me dis si je mets neuf il va
sûrement mettre moins parce qu'il va
savoir que maintenant bref c'est pas mal
de psychologie et au final je pense que
il peut y avoir des cas où les joueurs
si les deux joueurs savent qu'ils
veulent absolument les noirs et ben ils
peuvent descendre assez bas dans les
enchères pour prendre des Noirs
absolument
donc voilà à voir
mais pour l'instant on n'a pas eu encore
de cas
où il y a eu des bêtes de 3 minutes ou 4
minutes ça ça c'est pas généralement tu
vois vraiment
le on va dire que le temps à peu près
standard qu'on a vu dans tous les paris
d'enchères c'était entre 9 et 10 minutes
c'est très standard
donc là tu commences à avoir par exemple
9 minutes
avec les Noirs donc tu peux faire nul
mais en face tu as 15 minutes donc 15
contre 9 quand même une grosse
différence de temps donc tu as les
blancs donc avec les blancs
en commençant la partie donc en
attendant au début tu as les blancs
et tu as plus de temps mais en face tu
as la nul donc c'est c'est assez cher
j'ai l'impression
c'est assez fort
alors la finale à quelle heure c'est la
finale ça va dépendre de
[Musique]
la suite ah ça a commencé Laurent donc
ça c'est la dernière partie
de ce match en armage et donc le temps
qu'il va paraître très très bientôt et
alors si Laurent Gate est parti il va
rejoindre un match
il va rejoindre un match
contre le gagnant
de son tableau
et le mals aura lieu aujourd'hui
mais là je sais pas trop
par contre si il perd cette partie là et
Ben et ben Laurent sera éliminé de
répétition
avant ça ne marcheur généralement c'est
du Blitz en emmagasdon et souvent c'est
4 contre 5 ou 5 contre 6 ça dépend
mais là je trouve que l'on cherche c'est
marrant parce qu'il y a un peu de
psychologie dans tout ça et j'aime bien
la psychologie
j'aime bien la psychologie elle est
et ça a commencé on voit 15 mais voilà
11 à 11 39 il a mis avec
donc les scandais bien bien tiré je
pense Laurent dans cette partie parce
qu'il a les Noirs il sait que la nul lui
permet de de se qualifier et il a
seulement trois minutes de retard sur ce
point adversaire ce qui est au final
pas énorme généralement on peut miser un
peu plus
et donc
intéressant en tout cas
malheureusement j'ai pas le pari de
[Musique]
joueurs on sait que c'est 11.39 le Paris
de Laurent mais on connaît pas le pari
de son adversaire
parce que
sur sur mon slack et ben il ne lisent
pas il y a que la division 1 qui est
qui a été
qui est suivi à ce niveau-là donc là par
contre maintenant c'est du chaos donc il
y a beau avoir écrit en dessous là 15 +
3 ben là c'est pas vrai là c'est du
chaos donc il y a pas de rajout de temps
à chaque coup c'est vraiment
dès que tu joues
pas très longtemps quoi
ça c'est pas standard si c'est standard
hein pour l'instant j'ai pas encore
comment commencer à commenter parce que
la position elle est hyper normale ils
sont elle a été vue des milliers des
milliers de fois donc c'est assez normal
cette position
donc là il y a plein de systèmes
différents avec les blancs mais investit
beaucoup donc bien sûr qu'il connaît
avec les blancs mais je pense qu'on va
juste il réfléchit à quel système il
veut employer contre Laurent
C5 et c'est la même partie que tout à
l'heure il me semble
comment
il a quand même un
pire attrapé déjà
il y a que
l'avantage du temps dans l'armée
et ben c'est important donc il faut
essayer de jouer vite il y a pas de
rajout de temps il y a pas dans le temps
à chaque coup il y a pas d'incrément
donc avoir une avance au temps c'est
d'autant plus important ici
que que en temps normal
et donc il faut vraiment jouer vite
ok donc tourner avec les jouets pression
sur un petit pion en dessin
comment est-ce qu'on répond à ça
je pourrais manger hein excuse-moi je
vous prends j'ai l'impression que les
Blancs ont un bon développement moi j'ai
un problème sur mon petit fou C8 B4 d'un
point à trois je pense
je pense
qu'à valider deux
c'est étrange surtout pour moi
il veut qu'il y avait les B3 sur moi
OK
avant j'étais [__] du coup
on prend j'avais d'enfants le fameux
clouage
ça ça
en fait même je pense que même
dans des tournois
comme la Coupe du Monde ou comme je peux
la France maintenant qui se joue en
système coupe même ce système en fait il
est intéressant je parle le système de
double élimination on a déjà parlé hier
pendant le stream mais quand elle est
quand tu perds une partie quand tu perds
un match et ben dans cette tournoi et
ben tu es éliminé mais quand tu perds un
match
dans ce tournoi là qui est le champ
Manchester
et ben au final tu tu as encore une
chance de de survivre
c'est super un deuxième match en fait je
pense c'est intéressant ce petit système
disons que le chaos c'est après deux
matchs après deux défaites
je trouve ça cool
par exemple on a vu sur la France cette
année on a vu la première ronde jus de
Moussard qui a donné une pièce dans une
partie et être éliminé être éliminé au
premier tour bah après c'est sa faute il
a mal joué il aurait pu mais
vous voyez ça je trouve ça un peu
dommage de punir un joueur qui si
on dit
si offensif quoi c'est un genre vraiment
qui je pourrais gagner tout le temps
c'est un joueur vraiment qui qui aurait
mérité de jouer pour le titre
et là perdre un match perd une pièce qui
lui fait se faire éliminer je trouve que
c'est cruel c'est le jeu c'est comme ça
mais je trouve que le système il est
quand même difficile alors que si tu
avais une double élimination
et ben
[Musique]
et je suis pas d'accord ça va rester
plus fort je suis pas d'accord
pas d'accord parce que toi dans le dans
le enfin
pour moi les favoris elle est plus forts
ont été les mecs comme très vite tu vois
leur enfreinet premier match éliminé
on voit aussi Jules Moussard premier
match éliminé on a vu aussi Christian
Bauer
pour moi c'était quand même trois
trois des joueurs les plus les plus
forts et
en fait non je pense que ces systèmes et
bien favorise les joueurs qui sont le
plus en forme qui font moins de bêtises
etc
pas forcément les meilleurs et
même si bon le champion actuel
[Musique]
c'est un excellent genre
mais
je trouve que c'est dommage
enfin une bêtise était éliminée alors
qu'il y a un double élimination bah
tu as le droit à une erreur droit une
heure
et je trouve que c'est un système qui
est intéressant au début je vous cache
pas au début je
critiquais un peu ce système je trouvais
que c'était un peu bizarre quand même
mais plus je le vois plus je trouve
c'est juste en fait
donc voilà c'est après c'est mon avis
c'est bon on n'a pas tous même avis
existe salut ciel bleu
et donc voilà salut à toi Oliver salut à
tous
les infos en fait c'est pour le rings
c'est une sorte de boîtier que tu peux
avoir chez toi qui mesure la qualité de
ton air et c'est un des des
sponsors de l'événement donc du coup
chaque joueur a un boîtier chez lui et
chaque joueur du coup mesure l'air donc
je peux je peux vous montrer ça
plusieurs joueurs malheureusement j'ai
pas j'ai pas je peux pas vous montrer
chez Laurent pour savoir si c'est
s'il fait bon chez lui mais
j'ai pas mal de joueurs
l'est indienne c'est mon ouverture de
cœur
rien ne peut pas te laisser dans mon
moi toute ronde et mieux qu'un favorise
la régularité aussi ben plein de débats
il y a plein de débats moi je suis moi
je suis contre le système actuel
et après c'est vrai que
le système tout ronde je trouvais ça un
peu monotone des fois
dans le sens où j'avais pas forcément
allumer l'ordinateur pour aller voir
absolument ce qui se passe dans le
National alors que maintenant comme
c'est avec l'élimination c'est vrai ça
fait plus spectacle tu as plus envie de
voir ce qui se passe parce que tout peut
changer en une ronde
mais je suis pas d'accord avec le
système d'élimination actuelle
maintenant commencer par contre je
trouve qu'elle une élimination c'est
intéressant mais pas comme ça
et un toute ronde c'était bien il faut
de l'époque mais c'est maintenant tu
regardes un peu moins en fait
actuellement c'est triste à dire mais
les échecs
les échecs spectaculaires que les gens
aiment regarder et ben c'est des Blitz
c'est des rapides c'est des chèques où
il se passe des choses et quand tu fais
national pour qu'il y ait pour qu'il y
ait que des parties nulles et ben les
gens au moins envie de regarder c'est
une triste réalité de la situation
actuelle des échecs mais c'est comme ça
et moi je fais partie des gens qui
aiment bien en fait moi j'aime bien tout
et mais je trouve que si
on fait un système d'élimination je
pense très bien d'avoir un ticket
supplémentaire comme ce système là qui
je trouve assez juste au final
par la moitié des joueurs oui bah oui
c'est clair et quand tu vois aussi quand
tu vois aussi que tu as des jeunes alors
moi je parlais aussi il y a des jeunes
joueurs qui sont très talentueux on a vu
Joseph Girel on a vu on a vu mal Boyer
on a vu etc des joueurs qui aimeraient
bien je suis sûr que tu demandes à
Joseph Girel qui d'ailleurs a sorti à
sortie alors je suis sûr que tu demandes
à virer si il préfère un toute ronde il
préfère un tournoi par l'élimination moi
je suis sûr qu'il va te dire tout le
monde parce qu'un joueur comme ça c'est
un joueur qui veut progresser et c'est
un genre qui veut se mesurer à tout le
monde dans national donc quand tu es
maître international quand tu es un
jeune grand maître aussi et bah tu veux
te mesurer au second de France tu veux
te mesurer à tous les joueurs et pas un
seul parce que là bon Joseph il a qu'à
me diminué Laurent et après il a perdu
contre Yannick Gozzoli mais il a un jeu
que deux joueurs et je pense va pouvoir
comme lui aurait envie de se mesurer à
d'autres joueurs
que
en tout cas elle aurait été content de
pouvoir jouer contre tous les joueurs de
du National c'est comme ça qu'on
progresse en juin est meilleur et
malheureusement que ce système mais il
parle que un ou deux pas en jeu plus
parce que si l'enjeu plus qui se gagne
tous les matchs et à ce niveau là c'est
quand même hyper dur
donc voilà il y a je pense que le
système est intéressant mais ça c'est
limite et je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec ça mais après
c'est pas moi qui fait les
qui prend la décision mais après c'est
compliqué parce que
je suis d'accord que les échecs ça
évolué un petit peu et il en faut peu
pour tout le monde
suivre un petit peu l'évolution donc je
suis d'accord pour le changement de
manière générale mais celui-là je l'aime
pas trop trop je suis c'est mon avis
c'est mon avis perso après bah écoute
chacun a son avis moi je m'exprime sur
le mien mais
mais voilà
je trouve président
[Musique]
oui bah c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais en fait si vous voulez
je pense qu'on peut toujours trouver des
arguments pour et contre chaque système
on sera jamais d'accord c'est comme les
départages
Armageddon du code
en fait il y a pas de départage juste à
chaque fois il y aura des trucs il y
aura des il y aura quelqu'un qui va être
les épée peu importe le départage bah
c'est comme ça à un moment donné faut
prendre des décisions il faut agir enfin
un truc et donc moi je trouve ça cool
que la fédé est quand même est décidée
de changer un petit peu le système parce
que bah c'est bien le changement je
trouve ça cool
mais
c'est facile de critiquer de la part
critiquer un truc qui a été fait mais
par contre voilà je je pense que c'est
intéressant mais pas comme ça
et si j'avais la décision je pense que
je mettrai peut-être même le même format
qu'ici
après vous pouvez dire que c'est débile
parce que je dis mais
voilà chacun son opinion et je pense que
c'est un truc qui pourrait en tout cas
mériter
de tester
et peut-être en testant
et ben on va se rendre compte que le
système n'était pas bon
il faut essayer
et Laurent il est pas forcément très
bien alors Laurent il a quand même les
deux fous c'est quelque chose de bien le
cavalier a pas de case en B7 mais il y a
un très très fort pion passé en C6 qui
me fait peur donc il va falloir que
Laurent fait attention donc là c'est il
y a 6 minutes 30 chacun et la la
l'avantage c'est que ici Laurent a
rattrapé le temps de retard il avait je
vous rappelle qu'il a commencé avec
trois minutes de retard parce que
parce que tu es un ingrédient et qu'il a
les Noirs qu'il avait misé sur 11
minutes 39 il me semble
non en fait je dis un juste par rapport
à plein de choses je pense qu'on est
parti sur l'échiquier et peut-être le
plus juste mais bon
une fatigue une maladie ou n'importe
quoi
tu peux toujours trouver des excuses
pour des choses des raisons
comme un bucols bah écoute j'ai joué le
numéro 1 2 3 le tournoi et je perds
enfin comment c'est possible tu ajoutes
des joueurs qui ont perdu enfin il y a
toujours je pense
des gens qui vont râler peu importe le
système peu importe le départage peu
importe tout ce qui peut arriver c'est
pour ça que du coup trouver un truc qui
soit vraiment juste pour tout le monde
c'est très difficile
donc voilà
après qui a raison
ça dépend des gens
il y a des gens qui aiment bien certains
systèmes d'autres qui n'aiment pas donc
en fait c'est difficile de trancher
c'est vraiment dur
mais quand même pas quand même pas pour
moi c'est le championnat il est c'est un
championnat de partie lente mais il faut
que j'en parti lente
de la part de Laurent j'aime bien ce
petit coup qui vient contrôler un petit
peu les cases noires
difficile mais il a la paire de fou à
vous le savez les fous c'est vraiment
une arme hyper hyper forte
est-ce que si je joue F4
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire en fait sur F4
peut-être qu'il y a fou c'est 4 qui va
être vous voulu par les Blancs il a un
petit clouage si tu prends je prends de
partout je l'ai une dame et deux tours
dessus et fou c'est 8 a été joué la
jauge n'aime pas ça
pourquoi je ne sais pas
c'est très chaud et genre ils ont 5
minutes 28 contre 4 minutes 30 c'est du
chaos
plus de rajout de temps est-ce que F4
c'est pas un coup cela j'y pensais avec
Full C4 l'idée de jouer sur la pièce ici
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait maintenant
faut F6
comment est-ce qu'on continue la tour en
l'air
et absolument tout en l'air
il y a ce caballer aussi en prise
c'est que c'est tous ces chances ça peut
enfin les affaires de Laurent imaginons
imaginons plus tard on pourra faire ça
mettre le fou ici foutu le reposer et le
fou qui défendra le roi qui viendra ça
fera nul des grandes chances de nuit
dans celle-là et Laurent aller noir
Laurent joue pour la multi fait nul et
ben il se qualifie pour pour la suite
c'est un coup qui me fait peur c'est
Dame des 6
c'est pas ce qui se passe après ça me
décis et ça a été joué et leur dit qui
confirme que c'est un excellent coup sur
ce Dame des 6
si je mange là il y a cavalier prend qui
attaque la tour Evo 8
et le problème c'est qu'après tac tac si
je mange tout là-haut
en prise quand tout le bout j'ai pas
fait ça et ça et je dois sacrifier le
fou sur sur le pion c'est la grande idée
de yakuboev
en terme d'ici j'ai ça en prise aussi
j'ai ça en prise d'imprends tu reprends
j'ai tout emprise je crois que le seul
coup doit être d'un point d'arbre
pas facile à voir non est-ce que je peux
aussi fou aussi par contre
faut aussi ce qui contrôle la tour
d'être mangé et s'en fout le 6 peut-être
de faire d’apprendre à te reprendre
c'est difficile mais bon
il faut survivre ici
il faut survivre 4 minutes pour le rang
contre 3,40 et il a pris et là c'est dur
prise et tourner vite
parce que pour D8 c'est jouable
c'est la partie comment est-ce qu'on
défend
comment vas-tu
en même temps sur mon téléphone la
partie de
carvana qui apparemment en train de
perdre contre Abdou
c'est cette quête qui a été jouée waouh
je prends là il y a échec et je prends
le fou et ce pion que je réussir à
promouvoir plus tard
taureau D8 est-ce que je peux jouer
le retour
le
voilà le droit de multi stream twitch
Youtube je crois que oui
il me semble
que moi je le suis mais en fait moi je
le fais pas parce que si tu veux moi je
suis en ristrime
je ne suis pas le propriétaire de la
chaîne
et Abdou qui a battu
qui a battu
Cavana donc il va y avoir un Armageddon
dans la poule des
des perdants de la Division 1
il va encore un petit peu attendre pour
pour rentrer dans
le game alors fou des 7 du coup pour C2
comment est-ce qu'on comment est-ce
qu'on gagne avec les Blancs parce que il
y a un pion en C7 ça a l'air d'être
écrasant pour pour les blancs mais c'est
pas encore gagné comment est-ce que ça
se passe et le G5 de jouer fou j'ai
cette forcer
on s'en fout un peu c'est pas du tout
l'idée nous on essaie de faire dame tout
recette fou c'est 8 ah il a mangé un je
crois quand même F5 waouh F5 c'est la
mauvaise nouvelle on voit Laurent qui a
disparu de d'obs ça veut dire peut-être
que la partie c'est terminé sur faut
prendre F5 et ben il y a cavalier prend
celui de Tournai tour là et ça sera
perdu je pense
pas grand chose à faire ici en tout cas
la partie est très très difficile pour
pour Laurent à tenir est-ce que
est-ce que on a des coûts
ça a été abandon direct de Laurent si
prends comme ça il y a promotion dame
si je vais tout prendre ca va aller
prendre puis on prend ma journée
c'est imparable et ici la partie et
éperdu
pour pour Laurent dommage en Laurent qui
avait qui avait dans les deux parties
classiques où ça change et dans celle-là
ça a été difficile et la dame des 6 et
Laurent du coup qui est éliminé de
de
la compétition au deuxième tour du
Chester division 2 donc du coup on va
passer dans la division 1 alors dans la
division 1 pour l'instant ce qui se
passe c'est que
il y a eu il va y avoir deux armagidon
simultanées entre laser
Wesley et Caruana et à plus de Rohff
donc l'armée donc qui va arriver dans 5
10 minutes donc je vous propose de faire
une petite page de pub pour
pour régler les caméras de la Division 1
parce que là je vais switcher de la 2 à
la 1 pour récupérer les caméras de so
Wesley carwana Abdou etc et je vais
organiser ça et j'ai aussi voir avec
Laurent si il a envie de passer ou pas
donc je vous tiens au courant et je vous
dis à dans 5 10 minutes à tout de suite
et c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de retour avec un invité surprise qui
n'est plus surprise maintenant je crois
parce que vous le voyez en caméra donc
salut Laurent
salut Stéphane salut à tous yes
[Musique]
j'ai pas le micro de compète ouais
j'entends ça mais je pense ça va le
faire ça va le faire c'est vrai que tu
as un très très bon micro à la maison et
celui-là il est pas on sent que c'est
pas le même que d'habitude
à l'ancienne tu vois j'ai mon ordi et
j'ai pas le micro yes et donc Laurent
alors tu es parti alors tu viens de
perdre contre contre
ce qui s'est passé dans cette partie
ouais non les deux matchs que j'ai parce
que j'ai le premier jour j'ai battu
derrière
jusque là tout allait bien et ensuite
j'ai perdu artemief et donc il y a coupé
aujourd'hui où je vois des
bons le point négatif évidemment c'est
que je percevais match mais je crois
positif c'est que c'est serré j'ai des
chances tout le temps et je manque un
petit peu de
dans le Time Scrabble comme on dit dans
le take note mutuel je montre peu trop
de choses
j'arrive et surtout hier j'avais une
partie où j'ai trois minutes il a 10
secondes et juste après j'ai regardé
la réalité en face il a juste mieux
jouer avec moi et que c'est 10 secondes
et c'est 3 secondes après
donc voilà ça c'est un peu décevant
aujourd'hui je sais pas une première
partie assez compliqué ou je sais pas le
sentais que j'avais quelque chose pour
le moment j'avais rien j'ai pris trop de
temps et j'étais très mal et apparemment
j'ai raté un gain sur la fin ouais j'ai
raté un gain ou je le matais
donc
un peu un peu dommage mais bon je peux
pas trop me plaindre au vu de la partie
et
la deuxième ouais cette berlinoise alors
là plus personne me joue la finale vous
voyez que j'avais
c'était une histoire réglée mais il a
pas mal joué c'est intéressant ce qu'il
a fait j'ai quand même eu des soucis
même si une fois de plus avec assez peu
de temps il a encore
il a encore
il a perdu le fil quoi tout simplement
j'ai juste ce petit con c'est ça que
j'avais vu je sais que ça existe dans
des alors évidemment parce que le fou il
est en B6 il est pas forcément très très
bien placé et surtout les blancs
menacent toujours C4 C5 de pour pouvoir
fermer donc c'est très risqué mais je
sais que dans ces positions ça peut
ça peut marcher je sais pas si c'est
exactement cette position je l'avais vu
ou dans une autre mais c'est les choses
que j'ai beaucoup regardé c'est que j'ai
regardé beaucoup moins vu que personne
personne en a final donc ça fait les
souvenirs étaient assez vagues
est-ce que ça marche quand même ou pas
ouais d'accord
à n'importe quel moment non je suppose
à 3 à la place de ça tu en prends trois
cinq
et
là non peut-être pas ouais quand même
pour garder le pion mais bon ok ouais F4
mais bon effectivement
ça a l'air
c'est ça mais c'est ce qui m'a fait peur
sur la position finale c'est les deux
pions pas payer c'est-à-dire que quand
c'est lié en face il y a toujours un
risque plus de temps
et pas bien avant voilà dommage et donc
le beat pour la marque donc j'ai gagné
le j'ai fait le alors c'est pas la
division ici parce que division 1 Magnus
et compagnie ils font des bides à 8,30
parce qu'ils ont des ils sont
extrêmement formulaires ils ont une
capacité à oublier 1142 et le sien était
à 12 30 12 30 on n'avez pas les j'avais
pas les bêtes je les voyais pas tu sais
je n'avais pas
j'aurais pu prendre les blancs quand
même mais
tu choisis ça marche comme ça c'est un
peu bizarre le système mais
effectivement
bon je me suis dit quand même 1142 ça
fait quand même c'est quand même
énormément de temps donc je me suis dit
on allait prendre les Noirs peut-être un
peu avant là je regrette un moment dans
cet Armageddon
ou un peu avant quand il fait
kb4 que je prends et AB
je sais pas dans quel dans quel monde je
joue pas de mb5 ici
je sais pas pourquoi je suis pas dans
mes seins c'est quand même pas très dur
à voir
s'il veut pas perdre son pion
il est obligé de faire qu'il prend des
capes
fais la paire de fou une position
ouverte bon bref après l'ordi mais je
prends le tour C8 il y a pas un monde où
je perd cette finale quand même
donc ça c'est vraiment dommage tu vois
c'est c'est dur de gérer son temps dans
les Armageddon bon c'est toujours pareil
ça se joue à pas grand chose
c'est difficile en fait moins de temps
la pendule tu avais réussi à revenir
autant
et ça te va et il m'a fait une belle
combine sur la fin parce que quand tu me
fais
j'ai pas du tout vu venir je pensais que
j'étais hyper bien parce que il a un
cavalier en
on peut faire des filles cool
si on revient avant après tu vois moi je
pensais que là ça va être bon parce que
son cavalier en B7
il a pas trop d'avenir il a plus trop de
cases
et j'ai pas du tout vu
en fait il me l'a
il me menace c'est ça
moi on me demande de baisser le son je
baisse le son et au final c'est plus
quand est-ce qu'on t'entend vraiment
je pense que je l'ai mis au milieu donc
ça devrait aller
non
d'accord donc voilà là je pensais tu
vois si on regarde que des est-ce que
les gens m'entendent vraiment
ouais en fait là le truc c'est que
stratégiquement j'ai gagné quoi parce
que ce cavalier en B7 ok ça a pas du
tout bon il y a pu passer en C6 certes
mais je le contrôle bien avec mon
footcas noir et sinon il y a mon
footcesse blanche en dernier défenseur
enfin pour moi là je suis très très bien
mais effectivement
j'ai complètement sous-estimé cette
histoire de fou ces 8 F4 et pour lui
rendre
hommage sur ce coup là parce que j'ai
pas du tout vu et c'est très joli ils
sont fous ces 8 F4 Dame des 6 c'est je
suis complètement fou
je vois un peu vite certes mais bon j'ai
moins de temps tout ça non je regrette
un message c'est quand même j'ai 7
minutes à la pendule j'ai pas trop le tu
vois j'ai dépensé que enfin je veux dire
j'ai pas le droit de rater sur de classe
d'accord
donc
voilà mais une expérience positive parce
que c'est la première fois que je me
qualifiais pour la division 2 donc je
progresse
qui reste il reste je crois que que deux
éditions alors
et une seule fois
une seule édition et ensuite il y a la
grande finale donc je fais des progrès
je sens que évidemment je parle pas des
des monstres que tu vas commenter là les
raisins Magnus wesleaux tu vois je te
remets une
allez une quinzaine qui te sent vraiment
à tout ça torov qui sont complètement
intouchables mais le reste tu vois quand
je joue Artémis
tu vois je sens que si je jouais un tout
petit peu mieux un tout petit peu plus
vite que je panique un peu moins
c'est jouable quoi donc ça c'est pas ça
c'est sympa
et donc c'est sympa de jouer ces trucs
moi ça me
ça me plaît c'est du rapide
si tu perds tu arrêtes tu gagnes tu
continues non ça c'est un format qui est
très sympa tout à l'heure j'en parlais
alors je vais te demander un petit peu
ton ton avis ton opinion là-dessus parce
qu'en fait on a comparé ça un petit peu
avec le format et le chocolat de France
donc tu as aussi un peu été victime
est-ce que moi je pensais que alors là
toi est-ce que est-ce que tu es de
manière générale pour les éliminations
directes dans ce type de championnat ou
pas
complètement je préférais je préfère
j'ai dit
je préfère la formule de l'année
dernière qui en fait qui était
exactement la même mais à part j'ai fini
le troisième et je veux jusqu'au bout
mais
à ah non bien sûr bien sûr non mais je
crois qu'il faut jouer je crois que
c'est faut s'adapter au
public et toi comme moi on est habitué à
commenter et on sent ben tout simplement
il y a plus de monde qui regarde il y a
plus d'engouement quand c'est cette
formule à Émilie direct il y a plus de
lisibilité il y a une grande finale tu
vois Manu ça les resa tout le monde a
envie de voir ça attends est-ce que tu
auras toute ronde il y a aucune
visibilité tu as la dernière ronde tu
joues l'avant-dernier bref ça a pas de
sens en plus ça empêche que quand tu
joues mal bah tu pars en fait tu parles
tu arrêtes le tournoi donc
voilà après il y a des petits accidents
qui arrivent mais c'est comme ça c'est
pareil au tennis à Roanne hausse dans un
endroit du Grand Chelem c'est pareil au
foot en Coupe du Monde tu peux perdre
sur des penalties tu vois qu'ils sont un
peu l'armée dans aux échecs c'est sport
je suis d'accord et en fait j'expliquais
un petit peu au chat un petit peu le
fait que savait que maintenant chaque
rapide c'est un peu ce qui est ce qui
est en dire à la mode et ce qui est
suivi par tout le monde en fait et c'est
vrai qu'un tournoi tout tronc bah au
final tu suis beaucoup moins qu'un
tournant parallèle à son direct et ça
c'est clair c'est pour ça aussi que
cette formule je la trouve intéressante
par contre je me demandais ça c'était un
petit peu le débat qu'on avait avec le
chat c'était est-ce que tu penses que
une formule comme celle-là pourrait
éventuellement remplacer
c'est le chocolat de France c'est-à-dire
une formule à double élimination comme
celle-là ça donne un type chance en cas
de défaite alors ça j'y ai pensé mais le
double élimination il est compliqué à
mettre en oeuvre au niveau des dates
c'est-à-dire quand tu réfléchis quand tu
es organisateur comment tu fais ou alors
tu joues à la deuxième élimine une fois
que tu es éliminé tu joues plus que
rapide
et tu reviens et alors ça devient
bizarre
donc là ça devient bizarre ça devient un
tournoi mi classique mi rapide ce qui
moi me choquerait pas mais tu sais il
faut que faire chaque chose en temps
dans mes franchement là cette année il y
a eu Jul et moi on a été éliminé dès le
départ effectivement mais quand on
regarde par exemple l'année dernière tu
vois tu as eu une finale mousse à Bacro
j'ai terminé le troisième donc c'était
le respecter par duelo on peut pas dire
que le vainqueur de cette année Yannick
godzzoli il est pas passé il est passé
très très proche plein de fois tu auras
de partir classique donc c'est largement
mérité il aurait pu gagner ce tournoi en
toute ronde romain Édouard bah il a déjà
été champion il a joué les il a joué
première place on voit un petit grain de
gardien qui était rubis final a joué
déjà a été déjà champion de France et
Maxime Lagarde qui était de l'autre
demi-finaliste
aussi été champion de France donc on
voit que finalement il y a la petite
surprise de la première honte tu vois
les deux petites surprises combinées tu
vois qui ont fait que les gens peuvent
se poser des questions mais en vrai
[Musique]
venez me voir j'aime jamais arriver en
même temps je suis pas de France merci
c'est extraordinaire que le spectacle on
a adoré on a tout suivi et Machin donc
en fait je crois qu'il faut vraiment
se placer du point de vue du public ou
alors on considère que on a trop de
spectateurs qui a trop de sponsors que
les échecs et un jeu qui intéresse trop
de monde et du coup on arrête tout et on
fait un truc
que personne ne peut lire qui dure des
heures ou l'avant dernier je vous le
premier à la dernière ronde voilà
personne ne comprend rien et moi je
pense pas je pense pas qu'on est assez
de spectateurs et donc je pense qu'il
faut mettre ça en avant non je pense par
exemple je pense qu'il faut profiter un
peu de la hype en ce moment et surfer un
peu sur la vague quoi donc même je crois
même même sans ça c'est un rêve en fait
je crois qu'il faut parce qu'il y a un
pour tous les goûts tu vois ce qui
aiment les parties classiques et regarde
les parties classiques
la carte yoga peut-être pas été break il
y a plus de gens qui regardent tie-break
moi le seul truc de la forme du seul
truc que je changerai dans cette formule
c'est
il y a une interdiction proposée
simplement la première moi je m'étais à
30 je mettrai à 30 coups parce qu'en
fait c'est toujours pareil c'est avec
les joueurs ils jouent avec les Blancs
tu vois ils ont rien à l'ouverture du
coup il propose une après une et après
les gens se plaignent qui a pas il y a
beaucoup de nul et tout ça donc si on
force à jouer comme à la Coupe du monde
jusqu'au 30e coup je crois qu'il y aura
beaucoup plus de résultats décisifs
parce qu'en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que en général le type qui a les blancs
il essaye un petit peu il a rien du tout
le type qui a les Noirs c'est pas mal
demain j'ai les blancs je prends pas de
risque et voilà ça fait des petites nuls
en une heure et c'est critiqué et je
crois que après il y a la fin il y a
l'élément de fatigue mais je crois aussi
que finalement gagner en partie
classique doit procurer un avantage
et en fait celui qui joue les départages
jusqu'à tard le soir jusqu'à minuit et
ben il a un désavantage parce qu'il a
pas gagné en partie classique donc moi
je trouve ça très juste donc je crois
qu'il faut
il faut il faut vraiment
il faut garder comme ça et peut-être
changer cette interdiction de proposer
nul la mettre à 30 coups 40 couches je
sais pas faire quelque chose qui empêche
qu'il est parti qui se finissent après
une heure une heure et demie
voilà salut laisse-moi te alors de deux
petites choses je sais pas c'est les
questions dans le chat mais deux petites
choses d'abord déjà énorme félicitations
quand même je vois ce petit ce petit
truc qui a été changé
en I ça n'a pas été en fait à la base je
voulais le garder parce que enfin je
veux le garder
non en fait c'est pas toujours pas vu
cette partie comme de 1500 là où tu
perds et ça remet tout encore
en plus alors bon je l'ai vu après mais
c'est un ancien 21 50 bon c'est pas une
excuse de quand même gagner mais
pas fait de mauvaise partie et tu vois
il comprenait quand même ce qu'il
faisait donc il s'était vraiment et en
fait la partie je l'ai perdu tout seul
je reste une tactique tout seul je me
suis pris un Caval étranger 3 alors que
j'ai une structure F2 G3 H4 il y a un
clouage champion F2 j'ai perdu trois
fourchettes quoi
et en plus il y a tout qui tombe
derrière enfin c'est pas donc très ouais
c'était le gros bad beat mais bon écoute
j'ai réussi
félicitations
quand même donc bravo à toi et
donc quand vous aurez fini de regarder
ça de regarder ce champion de chaise
tour qui continue sans moi
malheureusement il y a le je vais
commenter je me suis mis d'accord avec
Nathan je vais commenter à partir du 5
tous les jours à 11h30 le tactile il n'y
a avec le meilleur d'entre nous Maxime
va chier Lagrave qui va défier les
jeunes Indiens donc plateau très sympa
et Google je crois qu'un compagnie et on
va voir si Maxime qui fait un peu figure
de vétéran dans ce dans ce tournoi va
s'en sortir voilà donc à partir du 5 je
vous retrouve du coup en solo c'est la
nouveau truc en solo c'est la nouvelle
c'est la nouvelle école jescom c'est du
solo
et nous
sépare maintenant
il y a des économies vous voyez a priori
des petites économies qui sont faites
donc voilà donc je suis ravi de vous
retrouver voilà plus de panique dans on
va regarder les autres Pan on va
critiquer c'est là où on est quand même
le meilleur
[Rires]
moi je suis bien ici en te regardant
jouer
non mais ça me fait plaisir de jouer
c'est sympa en plus des très bons jeux
donc très bonne expérience de jeu le
truc un petit peu pénible c'est qu'il
faut arriver une demi-heure avant faut
quasiment montrer la couleur de ton tu
vois mais c'est normal qu'est-ce que tu
veux faut faire un petit un petit chèque
montrer le couleur de ta chambre enfin
tu vois montrer où tu es mais bon en
même temps on va pas se plaindre il faut
jouer dans un environnement safe et je
peux vous garantir que entre ça
entre les gens qui sont dans le qui
regarde la vidéo qui a enregistré
d'ailleurs les vidéos quand on est sur
zoom elles sont toutes enregistrées il y
a un petit message qui dit qu'on a
enregistré donc s'il y a un doute après
il y a vérification
il y a des gens qui sont là et qui
regardent avant les parties après les
parties qui regardent nos ordinateurs un
petit peu aussi voilà le gestionnaire de
tâches et compagnie donc ils font très
très attention à ça et vraiment c'est
c'est agréable parce que on se pose même
pas la question en fait de de j'ai pas
prononcé le mot mais de la triche sur
Internet qui qui a existait évidemment
et qui et qui tant qu'il y aura du jeu
sur Internet ou c'est pas pour les
échecs c'était pour tout voilà donc il y
a une il y a un gros travail de
prévention plus les outils informatiques
qui sont là donc honnêtement dans ces
dans ces champions
je me suis jamais senti gruger
donc voilà les parties tu sens c'est
chaud quoi tu vois
t'as ta chance machin il se passe voilà
donc c'est très agréable l'expérience de
jeu est très agréable et voilà bref une
demi-heure avant donc ça c'est pas
c'est agréable mais c'est pas un gros
problème non plus mais voilà donc moi je
suis ravi de faire ça et j'espère que il
y en aura l'année prochaine
en tout cas c'était tournoi donc
et puis il y a des beaux matchs là tu
vas commenter tu vois commenter notre
petit allié réserve face à face à l'ogre
qui sont en train de se en train de se
jouer j'étais en train de regarder
qui joue et
de rien suivre quand on joue c'est ça le
c'est celle défaut du truc mais bon
je l'avais déjà remarqué alors à plus
qualifié
et je l'avais déjà vu bon déjà j'avais
déjà vu sur internet à plus de 3000 et
quelques fois et ensuite je l'avais revu
au championnat du monde blitzer rapide
et j'avais dit bon bah on va voir un peu
ce qui vaut parce que sur Internet c'est
une chose mais après il faut prouver en
live et il avait fait un surface du
monde avec des Blitz assez monstrueux
quand même
ça joue à avoir au construction sur les
joueurs les joueurs qui ont la même
résultats il y a pas de raison de pas
avoir les mêmes résultats en globalement
on peut faire des mauvais tournoi
évidemment mais bon
d'avoir globalement les mêmes résultats
online ou voilà mais je crois que c'est
ce qui se passe quand on voit une finale
Magnus va aujourd'hui bon ça semble ça
semble être logique
il y a pas de scandale ça va être beau
ça va être beau à suivre
et là la David qui est en train de qui
est en train de gagner sa finale contre
soda
tu vois encore c'est pas c'est pas le
hasard
on peut faire à rikiki qui nous dit
rikiki dans le chat dans le salut moi je
sais qui c'est qui qui quitte la famille
Maxime pas du tout le format qui m'a
quand même accordé que quand je lui dis
il faut une finale dans un tournoi parce
que c'est comme ça les gens ils
attendent la finale il m'a dit oui il
m'a dit accorder mais pour le reste
c'est pas juste c'est tout ça mais c'est
le problème je vais
et tu sais que les joueurs la majorité
des joueurs et des joueurs sont contre
la formule mais je crois que c'est
honnêtement je vais me faire je vais pas
me faire que des amis mais je crois que
c'est un manque de
[Musique]
un manque d'expérience dans l'univers du
streaming et des commentaires en direct
ou on le sent que voilà voilà et
seulement et cette façon de je sais pas
de pas voir que pour démocratiser notre
jeu il faut faire il faut créer une
visibilité maximum et du spectacle aussi
voilà des créer des formats attrayants
pour les spectateurs et que finalement
et je suis bien placé pour le dire les
joueurs ne sont pas du tout la priorité
je suis vraiment désolé de le dire mais
la priorité c'est avant tout le public
et faire un spectacle un spectacle oui
n'ayant pas peur des mots un spectacle
attrayant tout le temps voilà pas dire
que
on peut pas lire c'est soit pas mérité
la victoire de Gozzoli cette année où la
victoire de Moussa l'année dernière donc
ça reste ça reste tout à fait juste
voilà soit un peu moins conservateur mon
cher mon cher Maxou
non mais c'est vrai non mais les gens
d'échec mais moi j'étais comme ça aussi
les gens achètent dès que tu recherches
un petit truc oh non mais c'était mieux
avant et tout ça mon petit tour à 9
ronde je passe ma petite semaine à
l'Alpe du S ou ailleurs avec mes copains
je retrouve non je vais pas partir au
bout de deux jours quand même qu'est-ce
que c'est que ces histoires moi j'ai
envie de voir mes potes je vois une fois
par an ouais ouais non certes mais en
fait
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça le sport
voilà il va il va me détester
on a fait des beaux matchs de ping-pong
avec Maxime Lagarde et ben écoute voilà
j'ai vu dans une vidéo tu sais il y
avait les petites vidéos
tous les jours il y avait une vidéo là
et franchement je trouve que c'était
hyper hyper sympa cette vidéo et dans
une des vidéos je t'ai vu claquer un
smash à Maxime Lagarde et c'était pas
c'était pas seul
j'ai perdu
et en plus il râle beaucoup et moi
j'adore cette pluie je suis content donc
le fils de
Glenn et Christine
donc cette très belle vidéo très très
sympa
[Musique]
je peux même pas me défendre
sur ces bonnes paroles écoute je vais te
laisser parler d'échecs ça commence ou
alors on va commencer avec Magnus là ça
y est les les
[Musique]
emmagasons sont terminés donc la poule
des perdants et donc on a la David qui
vient de battre Wesley sceaux et Abdou
qui vient de battre karwana donc les
deux Américains out d'ailleurs si vous
voulez voir un petit peu
[Musique]
le bracket qui est ici et ben vous avez
laservic qui va rejoindre Abdou en
demi-finale des perdants et le vainqueur
affrontera et ben le perdant de la
finale
45 Fillaud c'est un peu compliqué mais
voilà en tout cas on va suivre en fait
une fois une fois que tu as pigé le truc
mais en fait tu t'y penches 10 minutes
la première fois que je l'avais commandé
c'est bizarre quand même ce système mais
en fait bon au final ça c'est facile à
comprendre et honnêtement se concentrer
cinq minutes et puis c'est bon donc
ouais donc on a un très très bon marché
évidemment le
mal le vainqueur prend une très grosse
option parce qu'il va falloir
après pour gagner pour gagner pour
rebattre pour gagner deux matchs
derrière pour affronter
le gagnant de la finale donc du coup
c'est une belle option quand même ici à
prendre clairement on va voir et puis
c'est les matchs qui adore Magnus et il
a dit il voulait jouer la nouvelle
génération il est en face de lui dans
ses tournois internet avec carwana qui
vient parfois se mêler à la lutte mais
et Nakamura évidemment et so mais le
reste c'est du abdouce à torov du
lasavik
parfois c'est pareil il y a du
artéminaire aussi qui vient qui vient
qui vient jouer donc c'est vrai que
Google
je pense qu'il joue pas à cause du tabac
style
mais clairement il y a tellement de
tournoi en ce moment mais clairement il
a son duel avec la nouvelle génération
online et finalement c'est à peu près la
même chose
je te remercie ok merci à toi d'être
passé
je te laisse et je dis
n'hésitez pas à venir le 5 à partir de
pour voir du des échecs live du coup
avec Maxime
merci beaucoup Stéphane merci beaucoup à
toi et à très bientôt ciao au revoir
ciao tout le monde
trop cool que Laurent venir nous voir
alors je vais essayer de récupérer
les caméras des joueurs parce qu'on a
Magnus
qui va qui va affronter firou là et ça
va commencer dans un instant
je vais essayer de choper leur caméra tu
as une petite seconde juste donc je vais
enlever deux j'en ai plus besoin et là
je vais demander
les joueurs qui arrivent alors là j'ai
je vais avoir ici je vais avoir à lire
et ça
qui va apparaître il a apparu là-haut et
Magnus qui va apparaître
normalement ici c'est très très bien ce
qu'ils ont fait comme système avec les
zoom bridges là un Magnus qui
devrait être l'âme sa caméra qui n'a pas
été
pas parti je score à zéro
et puis je vais en profiter je pense
pour faire une petite pause 3 minutes
pose toilettes
j'ai pris une seule pose depuis le début
et je vous dis vraiment à tout de suite
vraiment deux minutes et dès que la
partie commence et ben j'arrive je vous
dis à tout de suite
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis de retour tout ça cette fois-ci
avec un compagnon
Magnus et Ali resa alors par contre les
joueurs ont l'air d'être concentré sur
une partie mais j'ai un petit souci chez
moi la partie assis
tout à l'heure je la trouvais pas donc
je viens de lancer
est-ce que la partie va démarrer ou pas
chez moi j'ai pas de coup
j'ai le 4 qui vient de commencer
à l'instant on arrive les pile à l'heure
alors c'est une Sicilienne
ouverte la cavalière
de la part de Ali resa c'est cool ça
ferait un peu de spectacle
de spectacle
pour le public finalement la nage d'or
c'est une ouverture qui est très
intéressante on voit personne qui joue
au tour géant dans ton géant c'est c'est
un coup hyper agressif G4 et attaquer
directement le cavalier et derrière le
roi le roi E8 donc une partie qui va
être très animée et tout à l'heure comme
le disait très très bien Laurent et ben
cartienne il a vraiment un coeur de de
jouer contre les
contrôler
la nouvelle génération et du coup il
joue des trucs assez agressifs et je
pense que vraiment il a envie de faire
plaisir dans ces dans ces matchs
donc très sympa ce petit tour j'ai un H5
alors H5 un coup un peu chaud mais qui
empêche quand même la poussée la poussée
G4 donc intéressant fou G5 de la part de
Magnus et Caval et BTS joué par Ali Rosa
classique tempo
alors j'ai une question pour le pour le
chat je viens de mettre mon ventilo en
marche est-ce que vous l'entendez est-ce
que c'est gênant est-ce que c'est alors
normalement j'en ai pris un silencieux
il fait pas trop de bruit je sais pas si
vous entendez un truc
dites-moi non s'il vous plaît
un peu c'est pas gênant mais non non ok
ça marche merci beaucoup parce que j'en
peux plus j'ai trop trop chaud je suis
en train de de juste mourir devant vous
ça se voit peut-être pas mais mais je
suis en train de là je l'ai dit au max
je l'ai mis au max justement donc merci
en tout cas votre enfin de vos réponses
c'est vrai que j'habite en Espagne à
Valencia et il fait un petit peu chaud
chez moi
même même très très chaud et j'ai la
clim chez moi mais avant la clim
n'arrive pas dans la pièce où je suis et
c'est vrai que que dans la pièce où je
travaille je prends un peu cher il fait
trop chaud
quand je suis là plus d'une heure ou
deux juste en fait je la porte fermée à
cause du chat qui vient grimper sur sur
l'ordinateur donc
en fait je suis un petit peu en jupe
longue quand je quand je dois stream je
suis obligé de me fermer dans la pièce
donc en hiver ça va mais en été par
contre quand il fait 35 degrés dehors et
que et que je suis enfermé c'est juste
pas possible le chat non si je commence
à la jeter maintenant
ça va pas le faire là il est il est il
est pas avec moi et j'ai pas envie
d'aller le chercher tout de suite mais
mais
pourtant mon chat il est connu il est
connu sur les stream généralement
présenté alors fous ces quatre a été
joué par Magnus donc c'est un coup hyper
logique de développement qui vient
jusqu'à 15 F7 à 15 très
très faible chez les Noirs donc là
qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici c'est que
souvent il y a des lignes dans la dans
la
le petit pion E6 n'a toujours peur vous
savez moi je connais rien et j'ai
toujours peur des trucs avec fupron ici
comme ça donc c'est pas et tout ce que
ça vaut mais
généralement il faut prendre juste ça
marche je crois qu'on le Fou est en le 7
ici et avec supran prise car elle va les
prendre à ta claque la dame puis le pion
G7 dans celle-là ça a peut-être pas
l'intérêt parce qu'à pas être prise
qu'elle va les prendre peut-être le
juste dame prend et au final le cavaler
il a pas vraiment de casse où aller
mais il y a eu G6 de jouer assez vite
d'ailleurs par Parly resa et Dame des
deux donc j'ai celle qu'en Rogue enfin
petit rock c'est une suite qui a l'air
quand même assez logique pour les Noirs
mais au final d'ailleurs les les blancs
bah leur plan ça va être de rock et de
balancer je pense un G4 un truc comme ça
et écoutez j'aime pas mal la position de
malus j'ai l'impression quand même que
et va s'amuser dans votre malus
c'est-à-dire le sourire aux lèvres il a
un musée et et
[Musique]
on aime bien se Mike bizarre qui est là
pour s'amuser qui voulait des trucs très
innovants et je trouve ça intéressant
les cinq débiles je pense pas
les joueurs se voient je pense que l'on
se voit oui les gens se voient alors
vite seconde B5 à ce moment-là faire
attention aussi avoir des coups comme
cavale et ses alors peut-être là comment
est-ce qu'on peut jouer ce que foudre va
les prendre des 5 et même plus on prend
des 5 à l'air extrêmement fort pour les
blancs parce que je n'ai qu'à danser 6
que je vais attendre ici j'ai aussi un
thème de qui peut arriver le pion de 7
qui arriverait je trouve que la
pollution est déjà dure et on peut pas
me voir fou G7 il y avait un problème
sur le pion 7 vous voyez
donc B5 ça ouvre un petit peu trop les
cases blanches pour l'instant je pense
et les blancs sont un petit peu trop
dessus et les joueurs se voient les
recevoir oui enfin s'il le veuille se
voit
si un deuxième écran ou quoi et ben ils
peuvent voir la caméra de l'adversaire
et je pense que bah c'est bien parce que
du coup on garde un petit peu le côté le
côté humain le côté
IRL ou des fois ben on est en face de
l'autre quoi donc je trouve ça cool
un grand a été joué par les Blancs et
que des coups c'est logique et puis ben
écoute F4 G4 5 tout va arriver et pour
Magnus les coups sont hyper facile à
jouer alors que pour aller raisin c'est
quand même beaucoup plus dur parce que
il sait que Steve aroquet va se prendre
du G4 et à se prendre du F4 il y a plein
de choses
et du coup c'est vraiment au noir de
faire attention
à ce qu'il veut jouer
donc franchement je mettrais bien cette
partie une pièce sur Magnus mais vu la
position vu tout ça mais on est
clairement pour les raisins qui est le
joueur français on va vraiment le
soutenir à fond mais j'aime beaucoup la
position de l'anus j'aime bien ce qu'il
fait en cette partie
et d'ailleurs ça donne envie des fois de
travailler un petit peu
ce type d'ouverture c'est une ligne qui
a l'air toute bizarre mais au final qui
a ça agressive et qui et qui est
intéressant parce que c'est pas
classique du tout et ça peut surprendre
pas mal d'adversaire donc c'est souvent
à commenter les trucs comme ça et dans
le final on arrive des fois à avoir
nous-mêmes des idées
des idées
dans les ouvertures alors salut Cécile
qui est de retour alors Laurent bah il a
perdu malheureusement la main guidon il
est venu nous voir
pendant un bon petit moment il nous a
raconté un petit peu comment se passe
c'est parti on a parlé un peu au
chocolat de France aussi par la même
occasion et du coup on est resté un bon
tu vois avec avec Laurent c'est très
agréable
et donc Laurent a quitté la compétition
et il y aura encore une nouvelle édition
je crois que c'est la fin du mois et on
espère y revoir Laurent présent lors de
ses compètes et il a perdu ouais
c'était vraiment difficile le format
alors d'ailleurs je vais vous changer ça
parce que c'est plus looser attendez
avec tout ce qui s'est passé j'ai oublié
de vous changer un peu tout ça là on est
plus en looser on est en
Twinner
c'est final
et
c'est le premier à deux et demi j'avais
changé tout à l'heure pour
l'autre poule la division 2 alors le
format rapidement je vais vous le
redonner c'est c'est des parties en 15 +
3 c'est des matchs en 15 + 3 en 4
parties à xP4 parties le gagnant et Ben
se qualifie pour
pour dire la phase suivante là c'est la
finale donc je vous rappelle qu'elle est
finale des gagnants et des perdants
c'est compliqué c'est un tableau assez
compliqué mais en gros là c'est la
finale des gagnants
tu mets vainqueurs ou tu mets le final
mais le Français le franglais c'est
bizarre
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que j'aurais
pu en fait
en anglais c'est c'est winner raquette
et loser bracket et là c'est la finale
j'aurais pu mettre
si tu veux je te l'enlever le
vraiment anglais complètement
te faire plaisir hop là et salut mala
c'était pas vu j'espère que tu vas bien
malin
c'est un bail que je t'ai pas
quand c'est pas écrit j'espère que tu
vas bien voilà
bah là je l'ai connu
autant d'avoine toi d'avoine très très
sympa ce tournoi et
avec ma là on a une assez goûté la fée
goûter de nombreuses choses on veut
terrer un peu sur le stream mais
franchement j'ai passé une super semaine
à avoir c'est trop cool
donc tourage
pardon était en et au final la pollution
blanc valait vraiment facile et on voit
bien que mcnus va vouloir pousser au
sort alors soit faire un F4 5 qui est
l'idée clair pour attendre la position
avec un vis-à-vis de la tour sur le roi
mais il y a aussi autre chose qui est
intéressant c'est genre de faire des
cavaliers des 5 qui peut attaquer la
dame attaquer le cavalier aussi attaquer
le pion de 7 qui peut aussi être une
cible et après un cavalier des cinq qui
avaler prend puis on prend on va avoir
un petit peu le même
problème qu'on aurait pu avoir tout à
l'heure donc je vais jouer un coup au
hasard juste pour comprendre l'idée
qu'elle est simple qui va les prendre
puis on prend ou après la prise du pion
ben j'ai la colonne E qui s'ouvre avec
le pion arriéré en E7 donc il y avait
qui peut jumper aussi en C6
et
la personne noire qui serait totalement
totalement
[Musique]
donc donc
cavalier 5 reste une très grande idée
pour les blancs il y a aussi f4.5 et
la potion d'ambiance qui est très facile
à jouer et
Magnus qui a déjà gagné 4 minutes à la
pendule
c'est dur pour pour aller raisin cette
partie
avoir j'en sais rien alors je suis pas
du genre à planifier mon agenda un an à
l'avance
je l'avais déjà fait quasiment 6 mois à
l'avance avec le groupe et je suis parti
c'était vraiment un grand record et
généralement je sais pas du tout
par exemple il y a un tournoi rapide
dimanche matin pas loin de chez moi et
je sais pas encore ce qui je vais jouer
c'est je pense que je ferai un pile ou
face samedi soir
savoir si j'y vais mais
sinon je planifie pas à l'avance je suis
pas comme ça
enfin en tout cas pas apparemment à
l'avance quoi ça c'est des fois oui un
mois ou deux bon et un an à l'avance non
à l'avance non ça n'arrive à mettre sa
reine en dessin
mais avant d'arriver avec Madame en
dessin c'est pas évident parce qu'il y a
un cavalier là j'ai un Caval au milieu
et c'est pas facile mais effectivement
ça peut être une arme tactique
intéressante
c'est la première partie de la finale
exactement ouais le score 00
les nouvelles d'Hélène non pas plus que
ça
pour aller raisin alors fousser 5 ça va
être dur à faire
c'est pas ce que tu as voulu dire en
fait
5 j'imagine que j'ai encore les idées de
faire E5 ou qu'avec des 5 dans tous les
cas c'est même [__]
maintenant que le cavalier est parti et
surtout prends j'ai cavalier 5 qui va
te casser toute la structure
là ça va être horrible d'accord tu la
bouges j'ai cavalé prend puis on prend
il y a ça en l'air il y a trop de
problèmes c'est catastrophique
et ufk de la part de Magnus qui est
assez logique l'ordinateur il aime pas
mais c'est assez logique F4 ça a été le
très vite d'ailleurs pour malin
l'origine de mon pseudonyme bah oui
c'est simple je m'appelle Stéphane donc
Stéphane stouf et en fait ça vient de
l'époque comme ma sœur était encore
toute petite et ben l'arrivait pas à
prononcer mon prénom et elle disait tout
et ça reste
c'est resté et du coup mon frère et ma
soeur m'appelaient tout pendant très
longtemps
et après en grandissant tous mes amis
m'appellent tous depuis très longtemps
donc franchement voilà c'est
naturel maintenant et la majorité de mes
potes m'appellent donc maintenant on a
tout
et les gens m'appellent tous depuis
toujours pas depuis twitch pas depuis
tout ça donc c'est stouf tout simplement
voilà c'est pas un grand secret
mais du coup je touche je trouve ça cool
c'est mignon en plus
je sais pas où je serai l'année
prochaine vous savez que dans la Manche
j'ai pas mal déménagé j'étais parti il y
a un an et demi non il y a un an et demi
je me suis installé aux Canaries en
Espagne mais avant ça j'ai passé six
mois en Argentine
et après il y a maintenant six mois de
ça je suis
je suis maintenant à Valencia en Espagne
donc c'est vrai que je bouge beaucoup
j'ai fait je crois que le confinement il
m'a vraiment rendu fou et une fois que
le confinement est terminé
et ben juste je me suis échappé je suis
parti de la France et
voilà quoi
dès que ça dès que ça parle espagnol
j'aime bien généralement donc reprend FC
donc là il a joué un truc qu'on avait
tout à l'heure évoqué pour éviter que le
cavalier il est parti de la case des 7
qui les font plus F6 et ben j'ai du
froid F6 et surfo prend il y aurait eu
cavaler des cinq qui attaquent là et là
et après l'échange en fait enfin
que ça bouge je prends un M6 et il y a
un gros problème sur DS6 ici et en plus
sur le roi donc on va pouvoir par
exemple du Caval et C6 dame bouge celui
d'en prendre 6 par exemple ou autre
chose en tout cas la structure devient
toute cassée et ce serait vraiment très
difficile pour pour les Noirs c'est pour
ça qu'il y a les raisins il a fait eux
prend un fils pour pas perdre son fou
dans l'histoire
et après F5 de la part de Magnus il veut
vraiment empêcher les noirs de sortir le
fou vous voyez en fait ici
si Magus n'est pas fait F5 c'est noir
qui aurait fait F5 vous voyez
et du coup F5 ça tue ce foulard ça tue
aussi ce foulard donc c'est vraiment un
super coupe usuel la part de Magnus et
roi H7 on est assez discrètement le
petit fou H6 qui va aller clou la dame
donc crois bien on s'enlève la diagonale
fou B7 et cavaler des cinq et là cette
position c'est un très très gros
avantage positionnel pour ma venue ce
qui en plus à 10 minutes contre 4
c'est dur c'est dur surtout prend faut
prendre probablement c'est un super fou
un super cavalier ce fou il est
complètement nul et je vais essayer de
pousser la majorité ici et aller
d'ouvrir à l'erreur je pense
le roi noir ça me semble être un plan
assez assez intéressant pour les blancs
ici à pouvoir faire s'en sortir c'est
une notion très difficile pour pour les
Noirs extrêmement
déplaisante en tout cas à jouer
je trouve c'est un son assez commun oui
ça marche malin bonne soirée à toi
bonne soirée à très bientôt au revoir
cette fois-ci
donc
logique des sites diagonales après ça
fait une belle petite menace discrète
mais c'était pas que pour la menace
quand même à ce niveau là ça voit tout
mais c'est juste pour améliorer sa
position donc il y avait aussi un fou
quand même sur le sur vis-à-vis du roi
donc en partant ici on sur la vue de la
vie donc c'est vraiment un coup un coup
double et ici ouais encore bien un jeu
de manus qui joue tout tempo il a 10
minutes 28 contre 3 minutes ma news qui
est hyper en forme qui joue tout
temporaire il a joué ici il faut prendre
des cinq il a pris G6
pour maintenant avoir le cavalier E6
finalement c'est juste c'est juste
masterclass encore toi aussi ce tour là
et une belle case dans le 6 beaucoup
trop dur ici pour pour aller à qui s'est
fait bien surprendre dans l'ouverture et
qui malheureusement ne va pas
en sortir vivant ce cavalier beaucoup
trop fort en des quatre le roi noir est
faible la structure est faible il y a
des trous de partout sur case blanche
bonsoir à toi sans sur le Baron Noir
ouais c'est la bonne partie sauf la cité
les deux mauvais fous c'est des noirs et
dure
donc tout revu de cavalue ici dans ma F5
tu es peut-être maintenant est-ce que je
peux essayer de doubler tout en fait
tout recadour 2 défendre ici et c'est un
jour G4 ouvrir le roi le roi noir
franchement extrêmement dur pour pour
aller raisin
qui a peut-être du F5 gain de temps pour
voir le foot peut-être c'est pas très
malin mon coup
malheureusement tu vas pas manger parce
que l'idée ce serait d'essayer de venir
ouvrir la colonache
3 et il va j'imagine faire G3 prendre
l'option comme ça pour pas il a fait
j'ai 4 waouh il a fait Magnus
du coup sur on prend H3 G3 je pense pour
pour garder la colonne Hermée je pense
pas qu'elle ira il a envie de tout
grignoter et après avoir la Tour Blanche
qui va arriver sur la colonnage je pense
pas du tout que ça soit
qui ne veut faire donc il a mangé parce
que tu as pas trop le choix au final et
H3 c'est pas un coup enfin c'est pas le
couple je regardais en priorité aussi
dans F4 tours géant ou tout le cas
maintenant il y a F5 du coup
à des raisins parce que du coup ça avait
l'air alors il a pas du tout joué ça
excusez moi je ne comprends rien qui se
passait quoi juste un truc que j'ai raté
ou ah oui pardon je suis fatigué je suis
fatigué les gens franchement ok ok
passons passons
maintenant il y a plus cavalier G5 il y
a eu le tour 3 G4 de la part de Magnus
qui la tour est incapable à cause du
vis-à-vis ici le pur a récupéré la
colonne G est ouverte et c'est
extrêmement dur à tenir
les raisins qui
c'est bien fait allumer alors cette
première partie Magnus quand il est en
forme franchement
il vaut mieux ne pas être maintenu
partie elle a pas eu à la pas eu de
tournée on va voir les Français
dès le début et des problèmes dans
l'ouverture et c'est pas trop quoi faire
et
il a jamais réussi à
s'en sortir et ma news qui joue tout
tempo et 9,47 cette partie 9,47 contre
contre une 19
[Musique]
c'est c'est ouf
c'est ouf en plus il a l'air vraiment
sur un il est tranquille chez lui
de la massette
il faut garder les dames quand même je
pense
sur le roi il faut garder les dents je
pense pas du tout que Magnus va vouloir
échanger les dames peut-être un dame G3
avec ton géant peut être sympa et aussi
tourage 4 qui peut aussi arriver pour
venir clouer le fou et le roi là-bas
mais ça m'a l'air dame j'ai trois
tout à fait normal
pourquoi il réfléchit mainus
en tout cas
alors il a joué tout ça n'a plus le on
avait plus hop
là il va se passer les choses 35 par
exemple
il y a trop trop d'avance au temps
donc il a le temps de
vérifier c'est clair pour G8 peut-être
un défendre ici mais il répète toujours
encore ce que j'ai 4 5 coups et bon j'ai
4 qui est encore plein de choses
[Musique]
et aussi Dame des trois qui est
intéressant aussi un pion F5 qui
qui va tomber je pense que c'est juste
perdu cette partie elle est perdue pour
pour
déjà que je vous le dis mais cette fois
c'est c'est la bonne dame des trois mal
alors vraiment très fort
en fait
pas défendre
le roi derrière en H7
c'est beaucoup trop difficile
pas mal
pour venir clouer ici tous les coups en
larbo pour les blancs mais moi je
regarde plutôt ici le pion ici il est
indéfendable
vous voyez même là je peux même pas
faire tourner la fuite
la Tour Eiffel qui menaçait ce qui prend
ici je prends et après je peux le
prendre ici enfin j'ai l'impression que
vraiment tout 100% tout est perdant
donc prend son temps
il va finir la partie
dans les règles
salut c'était pas une option de donner à
la tour contre cavale et un pion
trop fort aussi ça
à quel moment
[Musique]
où est-ce que tu parles dans notre truc
de donner la tour contre cavale ah
pardon aussi
en fait le problème
le problème c'est que oui tu peux
peut-être le faire mais en fait il y a
tout il y a tout qui tombe
en plus de alors je sais pas carrément
tu veux le faire peut-être maintenant
alors là je sens en l'air je peux pas
attends donc je peux pas sacrifier la
tour
il y a le fond en l'air
et là maintenant dans tous les cas avec
tu fais ça ton roi est tellement ouvert
de partout que il y a trop de problèmes
tu vois alors j'ai ça par exemple qui me
la ça qui menaçant
en fait la position elle est trop
ouverte le G5 en fait
tu prends là je prends là et après je
prendrai la
mais en fait en fait la position
elle est trop mauvaise et ton roi il est
ouvert tes pièces sont pas actives donc
[Musique]
et la photo c'est une bonne question bat
tout simplement que le cavalier ici il
est bien meilleur qu'une tour
j'ai pas envie de manger matériel dans
cette position où le roi est
complètement ouvert je préfère vraiment
jouer pour l'attaque et toi d'un métro
ici à la extrêmement fort et je sais pas
pourquoi mais Magnus réfléchit autant de
temps d'un étroit là vraiment
et
[Musique]
voilà franchement cavalez ces 7 tu
aurais pu manger une qualité mais c'est
un peu une erreur des froide d'aller
brancher le matériel des fois le plus
simple c'est juste de
garder la pression et de pour l'attaque
alors j'avoue j'ai pas vu ce coup là
c'est pour ça que pendant longtemps moi
je l'avais pas du tout
j'avais pas du tout vu et tout récent ça
a été le coup ça c'est un coup brillant
d'ailleurs de l'ordinateur le roi blanc
qu'il falloir qu'il va partir en H4
obligatoire et maintenant bah écoute il
a deux tours pour la dame
mais si je mate c'est fini
comment est-ce qu'on peut terminer cette
partie rapidement avec les Blancs
comment est-ce qu'on termine sa Magnus
dans mes chèques voilà
qui va revenir ici je peux revenir ici
si je veux c'est plein d'échec possible
la F6 a l'air bien aussi mais je place
rien en fait
toujours foutrant
noir arrive à se cacher et d'autant pour
la dame donc ça peut ça peut jouer mais
ici le roi blanc enfin le noir est
tellement ouvert que je pense qu'il
survivra pas à l'attaque à l'attaque de
de Magnus
salut à toi Jonas et merci beaucoup pour
pour tes petits mots pour ton petit mot
et oui c'est enfin arrivé incroyable
donc ton G8 comment est-ce qu'on joue
maintenant on peut ces pièces sont
désorganisés chez les Noirs il a fait
prise donc on peut s'attendre je pense à
tourtrange et 4
donc il est vraiment injouable il y a ça
qui tombe en plus
si roi là tu manges là pardon
il est venu ici je pense manger là
ta dame 5 toujours
après pour ressortir ta mission
qu'avance à des tours qui sont
désorganisés
je pense que c'est injouable et chaque
je peux même faire faire un B4 peut-être
sûr de bien cacher mon roi
ouais je suis d'accord c'est normal
d'ailleurs de sauter sur une fourchette
mais au final
au final
le matériel c'est pas le plus important
ça va être finir on va laisser s'il y a
des six qui va partir
donc là je défends aussi la case de la
tour il y a plus les chèques ici
ça les routes total
des réserves qui franchement
fait ce qu'il a pu mais là
l'ouverture c'est mal passé et il a pas
réussi à n'a pas réussi à survivre quand
tout doit gagner pour malus
tout doit gagner la Dame des trois qui
est intéressant avec des sets faire
attention qu'à la fois
voilà et ça attention à ça
je pense qu'il y a rien mais il faut
faire attention à son roi quand même
parce que moi je me lasse dame là haut
quand même
ça passe ça passe
mais c'est contre le jeu
c'est la partie ce qui va ajouter
je pense que oui
après en B3
encore le
la fin de la partie vous savez qu'on a
une minute de décalage avec avec
tes parties donc là je pensais je
pensais des 7 et surtout H1 voilà les
surprises on va prendre
et plus d'échec voilà
et si je fais ça tu prends ici pour mon
assiette ici je fais dans mes chèques
j'ai le trait
plus de suspense
et ça va être perdu
à mon nom
oui je pense c'est triche
je pense mais on sait pas plus donc
Magnus Lilian et cette première partie
franchement une partie juste
monstrueuse de la part de Magnus numéro
1 mondial on peut dire champion du monde
et puis du monde et donc ouais hyper
impressionnant cette partie et on va
avoir du coup la revanche de de ce match
donc la partie numéro 2 avec Ali resa
qui aura des blancs cette fois-ci et qui
aura à cœur de
de gagner et de revenir au score
rapidement donc je vais faire une pause
de trois minutes et je reviens pour pour
la deuxième partie donc je vous dis à
tout de suite rester parmi nous
à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis de retour parmi vous
alors je vais enlever ça hop sinon vous
allez entendre ce qui se passe chez
Magnus
alors je vois tout le score d'ailleurs à
jour Magnus qui a un
qui a qui a 0 donc la partie orange qui
va commencer je pense dans dans un petit
moment dans quelques minutes Magnus qui
est prêt déjà en découdre lors de cette
deuxième partie donc je vous rappelle
que
c'est des matchs de quatre parties en 15
+ 3
donc 4 parties maximum
sauf s'il y a un départage aussi donc le
match qui peut se terminer entre 3 et 5
parties par exemple si Magnus venait à
gagner une partie et demie sur les deux
qui venaient et 2 et demi sur trois et
du coup il y aurait pas de quatrième
partie parce que les map serait déjà
gagné
et par contre en cas d'égalité et ben il
y aura bien sûr une quatrième partie et
éventuellement un armag est donc
maintenant il faut que Ali raisin arrive
à
réagir et gagner une partie en tout cas
il faut pas qu'il perde si il perd une
deuxième partie d'affilée ça va être
très très grave pour lui et parce que
Manu ce qui va s'envoler
pour la finale du championnat alors
rapidement je vous montre un petit peu
le racket si vous voulez voir un petit
peu comment ça marche c'est comme ça
regarde on a 47 qui vient de tout
là-haut qui a battu tabac avec deux et
demi-heure et demi car on a deux et demi
zéro et demi qui maintenant il est en
finale vous voyez là il y avait winners
final
et en fait du coup il a rejoint
à furosa qui lui a fait par contre son
hantée il a fait 3-0 2 et demi et là il
joue contre 45 le vainqueur sur cette
partie ira sur la grande finale et
ensuite ce qui va se passer c'est que le
père Adam 2 a des raisins Carlson et ben
va jouer contre le vainqueur de la
loosers semi-finale qui est en dessous
et du coup le vainqueur de cette looser
final je vois contre
contre le gagnant de
de la finale des gagnants voilà donc
c'est voilà mais du coup le vainqueur
c'est ça si jamais imaginons le gagnant
de la de la finale va en grande finale
on va rencontrer un adversaire et ben il
peut perdre un match donc en fait
potentiellement le jour de la grande
finale et ben on aura la finale des
perdants le gagnant de la finale des
perdants jouera contre le
vainqueur de la finale des gagnants
et
si le vainqueur de la looser bas
le gagnant et ben il y aura un deuxième
match
ça me paraît logique parce que chacun a
droit à une défaite donc du coup tu te
grilles un petit peu un joker allez on
va partir sur la partie qui vient tout
juste de commencer avec une Sicilienne
ouverte pour ma muscade donc avec Caval
et 6 ça s'appelle la taille Manoff cette
position
donc elle va laisser 3
que le perdant du grand final
de rattrapage bah en fait orang-outan
imaginons si Magnus Carson a tout gagné
et qu'il est en finale
et Ben
et si il perd la finale alors que la
tout gagné avant il aura un joker par
contre le perdant qui de la fin c'est
compliqué mais le joueur qui vient de la
de la poule déperdant mais
s'il repère en finale mais il a perdu tu
as le droit à une défaite donc c'est
normal que le joueur qui est tout en
haut et droit à un ticket mais que celui
qui vient d'en bas n'est pas le droit de
ticket
ça me paraît en tout cas pour moi très
logique et dans une carotte j'ai pas vu
ce qu'il mangeait mais sinon j'ai une
carotte écoute
j'ai pas eu tout vu
ce qu'il mange moi j'ai horreur de ça
horreur des carottes il y a un truc pas
manger
c'est bien ça
en pas de copain avec
c'est ça c'est un baguette à double
élimination c'est exactement ça et donc
c'est vu c'est vraiment une carotte
c'est vraiment une carotte effectivement
je savais pas vu
[Musique]
bah écoute moi je mange ça je vomis vaut
mieux en direct donc pour ça que je suis
pas aimable du printemps
mais moi je mange ça devant vous là
ton grand rock a été joué donc Christine
bizarre enfin bizarre ça met trois ça
fait longtemps que c'est un petit peu à
la mode
quand c'est dans ces lignes tout à
l'heure on a vu un tour géant sur la
nageddorf de l'IRESA et là on voit un
bam F3 grand rock c'est que des lignes
qui sont qui sont pas trop classiques
quand même dans toutes ces siciliennes
le tout c'est un légume qu'on déteste
mais bon il y a plein de légumes que je
déteste j'ai un peu un problème avec les
légumes mais je je ferai vraiment des
efforts et avec chaque plage je mange
des légumes mais les carottes j'ai
vraiment vraiment du mal
et j'ai un d'ailleurs j'avais un
souvenir quand j'étais quand j'étais en
primaire vraiment tout petit et ben à la
cantine de l'école
tu avais cette dame qui s'appelait
Martine qui nous forçait à finir nos
plats et il y avait toujours des petites
carottes un peu hachées
en entrée et moi la carotte ça a
toujours été le truc que je pouvais pas
manger et sinon je peux pas enfin je
peux pas si je mange vomi enfin je peux
pas et elle te force elle te force à te
force mais écoutez je l'ai vomi dessus
et je l'ai prévenu et c'était très fier
de moi et puis et après elle va plus
jamais forcer à manger des carottes elle
s'en est souvenue mais moi je m'en
souviens encore je devais avoir
franchement je devais avoir 8 ans quoi
je m'en souviens très très bien le vomit
dessus elle a bien cherché franchement
je l'avais bien prévenu que il fallait
pas me faire fallait pas me forcer à
manger des carottes
et
si on pense à aider
bon du coup dame G3 il y a un petit il y
a un petit vis-à-vis sur la dame là et
un problème sur le pion G7 je peux pas
sortir le fou sinon je perds un G7 donc
comment est-ce qu'on joue ici avec avec
les Noirs première question
contrairement à tout à l'heure le V5
qu'on avait pas trop envie de faire
parce qu'il y avait déjà un fou en C4 et
aussi et pas de pions en 6 donc là c'est
un peu différent
H5 a été joué pour chasser la dame de la
case G3 c'est vrai qu'il me casse un
petit peu embêtante pour le noir avec le
visage il a tension sur l'option gs7
donc comment est-ce qu'on joue ce que H4
c'est un coup je pensais aussi à jouer à
un jeu fouger 5 pour attaquer si ce
n'est aussi empêcher
empêcher
H4 des Noirs donc il y a plusieurs
possibilités
n'allez pas chez le son de l'ail en tout
cas je te dis bonjour à Martine
oh là là tu es horrible
j'ai pas le bracket sous les yeux mais
s'il y avait si il a perdu contre ça
il aurait sûrement rejoint en looser et
cette fois il y a des gagne et rencontre
Magnus rendus
il avait perdu contre saut
il y a eu un cas où au Magnus a perdu au
Prom du match c'était contre artef
et il a donc il a perdu un match et dans
le loser pendant le braquet des loosers
et la tour gagné jusqu'à arriver en
finale quand on a qu'à moi
il y avait aussi un autre cas où il y
avait
[Musique]
c'était karwana qui avait sorti Magnus
je crois en demi-finale un truc comme ça
et il avait rejoué Margus en finale et
Magnus
avait par la pousse des perdants regagné
tu arrives en finale contre Kawana il
avait battu kervana et il l'avait
rebattu derrière pour gagner le tournant
donc en fait voilà c'est le système
comme ça je trouve ça cool
même le même truc avec carvana et à le
tournoi ou Abdou a gagné l'événement et
ben Abdoulay est battu car on a dans les
poules il allait rebattu en finale
il doit être quoi 5 à peu près
[Musique]
mais est-ce que c'est vraiment possible
deuxième aussi deuxième se tient en même
temps oui
il est 5e
ouais
en fait c'est tellement thématique mais
après Magnus en tout cas il se pose
plein de questions enfin il a peur s'il
s'en fout c'est par contre allez raisins
qui calculent bien et voir un peu ce qui
ce qui fait
[Musique]
je pense que Martine est la dernière
avenue tu finis
tu finis la carotte
direct il va
oui ok mais en fait c'est une position
ou un quel
filou était pas du tout à l'aise et
qu'on ne sait pas bien la position et en
fait dans les nage Nord apprécie ça peut
très très vite tourner mal donc en fait
c'est étonnant oui mais bon ça arrive et
regarde si firou il place qui avait des
dessins avec ça gagne et ben on pourra
dire la même chose de cartienne qui
s'est fait exploser
voyez en fait donc une mauvaise partie
on peut tous la voir surtout sur les
ouverte ou c'est ultra chaud ils peuvent
passer plein de choses tout le temps et
c'est un peu le spectacle c'est cool en
tout cas on est content d'avoir ça
[Musique]
ce qui peut changer
c'est que donc là là j'ai pas trouvé
par rapport à tout à l'heure
vous voyez dans celle-là donc
comme ça et ça peut être compliqué
d'ailleurs j'avais déjà vu des positions
comme ça une partie de dirige notamment
où il y avait un sacrifice de pièces de
ce type là et avec un truc de cavaler
des sites mais je sais plus comment ça
marche
peut-être que je dis n'importe quoi mais
ça me dit quelque chose
et en tout cas cette position je crois
que l'avoir
déjà vu en tout cas c'est un C3 vous
dites ça comment je défends
ça me dit un truc
fou BK
c'est tout maintenant par rapport à la
ligne et ben tu as plus le pion qui a
disparu donc j'ai trouvé
et tu reprends à deux c'est un peu long
je pense route parce que j'ai des
menaces de partout j'ai du cavaler ces
sept
il dira j'avais matin dans la partie
route c'est tout seul là il y a Matt
je vais revoir rapidement
tu prends à deux je te mate comme ça
c'est maths tu es un échec oups 4
et non faut B6
ok bon là c'est des lignes hyper hyper
hyper compliqué il y a lui qui avait les
baisser un gars c'est la partie et eux
qui avaient les dessins dame baby c'est
la partie
le Magnus maintenant qui est qui
réfléchit
qu'est-ce qu'il va pouvoir faire ici
j'ai l'impression que c'est fini en fait
parce que je menace à la fois ça mais
surtout je menace ça en fait
et après vous êtes j'ai l'impression que
c'est Ganda
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
alors matériellement j'ai une pièce
d'avance
donc je peux éventuellement essayer de
perdre la dame pour manger d'autres
pièces j'ai des idées comme tu reprends
à deux
qui permettent de vous donner une case
pour madame
mais c'est 7 et très grave ça peut être
kraft avec
plein de choses il n'est pas d'accord du
tout avec ce que je dis ah je viens de
voir la tactique pourquoi la date
d'accord il y a un très joli ça cuit de
dames après tu apprends cette
histoire full prend
la fourche royale et j'ai récupéré mon
matériel ouais c'est fort
du coup dans cette position je ne peux
pas jouer kaaris cette 3b1 ici
7 sur Damas 8 pour défendre j'ai
fourchette royale
sur ton bouge là-haut c'est 7 années
perdu son tour ailleurs maintenant vu
c'est
bon c'est hyper compliqué c'est les
liens vous voyez c'est en un coup ça
peut ça peut basculer d'un côté ou de
l'autre en tout cas en pratique j'ai
l'impression que c'est une horreur pour
les Noirs parce que des blancs c'est
assez dangereux
on pousse en pouce on attaque et on a
clairement la position pour attaquer et
pour tout envoyer donc c'est
c'est assez facile par contre pour les
Noirs il faut se défendre et je suis
clairement réseau de maths un peu de
partout et c'est beaucoup plus dur pour
les Noirs j'ai l'impression en tout cas
j'avais raison non la plus grande ligne
c'est B5
F4 qui avait eg4 fougères H5
on voit que les spécialistes dans le
chat
des lunes théoriques vous connaissez
mieux que que c'est beau
moi je connais pas trop ce genre de
ligne mais je trouve ça hyper
intéressant
après moi j'aime pas trop de base les
lignes qui vont jusqu'au maths les
lignes comme ça j'aime pas trop parce
que
tu as l'impression que c'est ton
adversaire il a appris sa leçon il va te
battre en fait et j'aime pas trop ce
genre de choses dans mon répertoire
j'évite généralement les trop grandes
lignes parce que j'aime pas trop
j'aime bien
[Musique]
j'aime bien avoir des pollutions où je
peux aussi jouer des chèques
donc j'aime pas les poissons trop trop
à la base je suis un jour d'attaque mais
dernièrement je me suis vachement calmé
et j'aime bien les positions plus
tranquilles et
[Musique]
ouais
salut Lucas j'ai commandé la 2400 et
l'eau derrière la table dépend à la main
donc je suis à 40 points dans mon
dernier tournoi donc ça sera environ à
2300 60 à peu près
j'ai beaucoup perdu leur demande
mais je vais revenir très très vite ne
t'en fais pas
il y a un très bon cours gratuit
ça y est ça part dans tous les sens
ça part dans tous les sens
dans mes trois avec les jouets j'attaque
là je me garde mes menaces
waouh c'est sport en tout cas je n'y
comprends rien
on y comprend rien
nuls
alors la connexion pour les nuls je la
connais et les échecs pour les nuls une
fois je l'avais offert un ami à moi qui
mettra international c'était pour le
troll
mais j'ai jamais fait et je suis pas sûr
que ce soit la référence
[Musique]
dans les livres d'échec
pour débutant
et ça c'est plein de choses
et là si je prends ici c'était quoi la
ref
peut-être juste non
c'est quoi la ref
on parle la chose qui sont tout en bas
apparemment F5 c'est le coup pour mettre
le roi en F7 ouais c'est c'est beaucoup
trop complexe
beaucoup trop complexe il a fait roi
bien tempo ça le coup
et en fait il attaque là il attaque là
et il garde ça en fait il y a trop de
menaces chez les noirs et à un moment
donné ça risque de
tour à 4 pour défendre le cavalier
au moins ça donne une case pour la dame
en 4 pouces et 7 il y aura dame là qui
me laissera d'ailleurs je peux pas faire
ça et ça pardon ça est simple parce
qu'il y aura dame là et mat en 1 par
contre cavaler c'est 7 mérite pas mal de
d'attention
et je sais pas trop ce que je fais sur
la main 7 j'imagine que je vais bouger
mon roi et ça sent
tout à l'heure je pensais à ça
ça et ça et malheureusement il y a pas
de matin je peux partir avec moi même là
mon roi s'échappe il y a rien mais on
peut tout regarder parce que ça peut
être joli et puis avoir des choses mais
j'ai pas assez
d'attaque il y a eu caresser trois
recettes et maintenant alors
matériellement il y a toujours une pièce
de plus pour le noir
mais le roi a eu 7 c'est trop dur quoi
donc c'est
chaud en tout cas c'est parti
je pense que je pense que les réserves a
gagné c'est parti
sur ma chaîne youtube donc pour ceux qui
connaissent pas ma chaîne youtube je
vous laisse découvrir c'est stouf qui
écrit sous mon pseudo stouf échec et
j'ai un how to ami où je commence c'est
parti le jeu
lors de tournois tournoi officiel donc
j'essaie vraiment de de commenter ça
manière plus honnête possible
et voilà malheureusement l'Europe où
tout est mis est terminée parce que je
suis passé émis depuis tant mais très
bientôt il y a une nouvelle collection
qui va sortir
un peu sur le même thème mais un petit
peu différent voilà voilà
d'ailleurs c'est pas encore fait la
dernière vidéo il y aura que c'est pas
encore fait la vidéo où je passe mettre
international je la ferai dès que le dès
que le que l'événement c'est comme là ça
va terminer parce qu'en ce moment je
suis un petit peu débordé
[Musique]
ces plateformes là et c'est aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux
et aussi j'en profite pour vous parler
de ma chaîne youtube vous savez que moi
aussi je suis enfin j'ai ma chaîne
youtube perso YouTube et twitch donc
pour ceux qui voudraient aller jeter un
oeil et ben vous pouvez venir c'est
aussi gratuit c'est pareil vous pouvez
follow pour rester en contact avec moi
donc ma chaîne youtube et ben c'est tout
échec donc tout c'est écrit sous mon nom
stuff avec un tiret échec et pour ceux
qui veulent aussi me suivre sur twitch
et bien c'est tout et c'est écrit sous
mon pseudo donc n'hésitez pas en tout
cas à aller voir ce que je fais
alors mec c'est pas ça un truc bizarre
il y a un tour des quatre
deux à l'IRESA qui n'était pas du tout
bon selon la jauge de l'ordinateur
pourtant le coup a l'air quand même
assez
forte on l'a toutes les pièces et après
ça je me lasse quand même pas mal de
choses à ça en l'air voilà pas de case
et c'est cavalier bout j'ai des coups
comme fou ces cinq qui ont l'air quand
même extrêmement fort donc il y a quand
même un problème sur les deux cavaliers
aussi donc compliqué
matériellement les Noirs en quoi
d'avance 3 4 5 3 4 5 il y a une pièce et
un pion de plus
et là ça récupère une pièce donc ça a
l'air quand même pas mal pour
pour les blancs cette partie après
dedans prend 4 qui va probablement être
le coup
comment est-ce que les Noirs s'en
sortent c'est ouf que la chose est noir
sont ok quoi
je trouve ça complètement complètement
ouf que les Noirs disent que la position
elle est ok alors que le roi il est ici
les pièces peuvent pas bouger alors que
les blancs sont complètement
c'est incroyable
ça c'est typiquement la position dans
laquelle l'ordinateur il va être 1000
fois meilleur que les humains
des cinq et je tempo roi bouge les fous
sortent
trop trop fort bien sûr les raisins il a
atteint un gain pour le moment mais la
position est
beaucoup beaucoup trop complexe
je viens de devenir ami mais je viens de
commencer à 15 ans c'est impossible
apparemment bah non c'est possible moi
j'ai connu un grand maître qui a
commencé à 19 ans d'échec
après c'est clair que plus tu commences
tard plus c'est difficile
de devenir vraiment fort mais il faut
pas désespérer tout reste possible ça va
dépendre de ton travail de plein de
choses mais
[Musique]
il a commencé à 19 ans et il est passé
grand maître à 25 ou 26 je crois comme
ça
il a commencé à 19 ans
après même je pense que c'est pas lié à
l'âge bon c'est sûr que quand tu
commences tôt
mais après tu peux toujours réussir des
résultats mais c'est clair que c'est
plus difficile et ça dépend aussi de ton
application et tout ça
ça dépend beaucoup de ton application de
plein de choses
Damien après je montrerai le gain à 21
alors on est en direct il reste plus
beaucoup de temps au joueur donc on va
stresser sur vraiment sur le live mais à
la fin de la partie on ira voir un petit
peu ce qu'il a raté à lireza parce
qu'apparemment il était gagnant selon la
jauge on ira voir ça après
pour ouvrir un peu la ligne
j'aurais voulu faire ça pour chasser le
fou et pouvoir brûler cavalier ça marche
pas du tout donc la cavalier
3 qui va qui va arriver et ici regardez
incroyable Magnus qui n'a pas du tout
ouvrir le cavalier là je fous des 6 qui
est le meilleur coup de l'ordinateur oui
la jauge hein
je prends là effectivement vous voyez
que Magnus est là du matériel d'avance
il y a un pion de plus donc plus je
change de pièce plus
je me trouve bien donc après la prise là
il va manger là
simplement
[Musique]
qui arrive un petit peu à s'organiser
dans sa position donc il y a toujours un
peu plus le roi toujours un petit peu
faible mais maintenant oui il y a un
gros centre de pion noir qui contient
quand même pas mal de cases et ça
devient difficile pour les blancs
vraiment de de
cet avantage que Magnus c'est quand même
bien sorti sa position et si on voit en
plus niveau temps il y a quand même 6
minutes d'avance pour les blancs pour la
noire pardon donc ça fait quand même un
bel avantage au niveau temps et c'est
hyper chaud c'est hyper chaud
parce que Magnus bon apparemment il est
mieux il a un pion de plus mais en
pratique ça reste une position
extrêmement dur à jour pour les deux
joueurs mais que le temps qu'ils ont à
la pendule c'est quand même bel avantage
Marius parce que comme le temps de bien
réfléchir le temps de de
bien tout vérifier alors que Ali hazard
avait 45 secondes bah c'est beaucoup
plus dur quoi l'erreur peut être commise
plus facilement de ce côté là
pour gagner
ouais on ira voir après
les blancs ils ont plus grand chose j'ai
l'impression que ça se 4 a été joué
c'est malus qui attaque en fait c'est ma
news qui attaque au final
comment tu expliques qui habite un grand
joueur de Bullet
ben j'en connais un autre comme ça je
connais un joueur qui est un excellent
joueur de Blitz un français un jeune
français un excellent joueur de Blitz
qui est très très lent
et même en blitz il est là mais à la fin
la souris il est hyper fort mais les
joueurs aiment bien aiment bien des fois
c'est un peu plus fort que et les
joueurs aiment bien se mettre un petit
peu mal au temps alors je sais pas
pourquoi il y a écrit Tchouk qui est qui
est qui est un gros exemple mais en
français moi j'avais Maël Boyer je sais
pas si vous connaissez il est à jouer
pour des jeux pour
pour Blitz
et il est souvent mal au temps dans
cette partie là
alors qu'en fait c'est un très très bon
buteur
faut pas que mais
il est tout le temps il est très très
souvent dans le temps
après
[Musique]
je pense que vous le connaissez Maël
merci connu sur les chats alors qu'avait
les Descartes a été joué et finalement
les noirs qui au fur et à mesure et ben
écoute finissent par
centraliser leurs pièces et reconstruire
un petit peu une petite cabane
avec le roi donc là on va mettre le roi
en F8 j'imagine
en commençant
il a pris un bail parce qu'il est il
jouait le il jouait l'événement
principal et je veux que je peux la
trans a été éliminé alors du premier
tour et après là je vais la création il
a regagné c'est un monde cadre aussi une
force de caractère c'est Maël
mais
je crois et avec les jouets
fou des 8 là on menace
en fait Magnus en fait la position avait
l'air complètement gagnante pour les
blancs
mais
mais bon il faut être précis et puis en
face Magnus
bah écoute rien quoi et tu rates ta
chance une fois
ben ça va pas forcément se reproduire
quoi donc là il résa avec 11 secondes à
la pendule pourquoi elle fut pas G8
c'est une bonne question avant dans ma
tête perso je voulais éviter les trucs
comme ça mais j'ai pas vu le fou moi en
fait je t'explique vraiment comment moi
j'ai vu les choses mais et puis du coup
ça me permettait d'aller sur case noire
et d'empêcher un petit peu les trucs
dedans mais sur damasut avec Anaïs V8
moi j'ai vu ça comme ça mais dames
devaient aussi être une possibilité
donc roi F8 qui a eu fou des 8 fou c'est
5 Damas 8 apparemment c'était un mauvais
coup faisait zinc apparemment il a raté
l'opportunité de pouvoir faire quelque
chose
non en fait ça va alors il est juste fou
mardi est fou je crois
cette position elle est devenue vraiment
trop dur pour
pour les blancs
parce qu'au final il y a plus beaucoup
de pièces qui jouent chez les Blancs
attention quand même aux petites
arnaques sur les cases blanches ça
pourrait ça pourrait tourner
l'accession si mon la masse gagne le 18
anciennes ouais
au revoir
en tout cas cet été il a été il a été
vraiment très très fort quoi norme de GM
à La Plagne il a sorti
Laurent chocolat de France d'ailleurs il
a il a fait des belles parties
franchement Joseph
[Musique]
il montre très grande qualité en tout
cas c'est parti dans son niveau de jeu
c'est un plaisir
en quatre à la pendule contre 7 secondes
et ça c'est chaud
un truc qui me qui me
pas simple en pratique si je prends la
bien sûr il faut prendre et là c'est pas
du tout possible il y a peut-être encore
fou aussi ce qui est possible en fait
peut-être ça a l'air d'aller encore pour
les noirs
on a vu s'il veut finir je pense
je vais finir
comment est-ce qu'on finit ici avec les
mains
pas spécialement
94 à ce point là mais c'est mérité
c'est amplement mérité
vu ces derniers résultats c'était
le match contre contre Laurent et le
match aussi contre il a perdu en
Armageddon enfin franchement
mais là je pense que sur le roi il y a
plus grand chose oui les pièces blanches
sont pas assez actives pour qu'il se
passe quelque chose dans la partie donc
je crois plus trop là pour
[Musique]
pour
aller résa qui est très très mal au
temple
il va se cacher le cavalier défend des
cinq donc il y a plus d'un point
et maintenant il faut finir à la partie
il mange là pour avoir le cavalier
contre le fou attention car mon casque
blanche
mais quand même de plus en plus avec en
plus une belle avance au temps
je pense ça va le faire dommage 7 mois
qui va partir se cacher
en décès en C7 sur une case noire
probablement
et des pions j'ai quand même deux pions
passés ça va avancer
tout seul je pense que c'est très dur
pour pour lire les hasard puis en plus
de ça j'ai quand même des coups comme
d'hab comme trois pour essayer d'aller
manger le pion sur échec
je pense c'est pas mal essayer de mettre
le roi sur une case noire pour pour
empêcher un petit peu toutes les tous
les problèmes peuvent y avoir sur 15
branches
8 F5
option il est il est en prise je pense
qu'il va le défendre dans mes chèques
alors correct il y a ub6
ou ici et on continue à pousser les
pions
sur la couleur du fond normalement pour
pas se retrouver bloqué
peut-être que la S4 c'est quand même
possible G4 m'a l'air en tout cas plus
logique ici
donc j'ai 4
allez la prochaine
je vais repartir par là
pas pousser des pions pour l'instant si
il pousse le plus rien il perdra pion en
G
dame ici peut-être qu'avait laissé ce
qui est un jour va être aussi une
possibilité et donne le pion mais
souvent est-ce qu'on veut le pion on va
le but de ma venue dans cette position
c'est juste de pousser les pions donc en
fait je pense que oui il va lancer 5
hein le roi de Magnus
attention de pas s'en battait quand même
3 ça va commencer à grignoter un peu les
pions et des maths qui peuvent arriver
comme ça
donc échec si je vais ici Adam c'est 5
voilà x 4 d'apprendre à 4 d'accord
[Musique]
aux problèmes de d'enfilade
voilà il y a plein d'échecs partout là
faire attention
sur F4 d'un échec roi là
on repart par ici je pense
et chaque là il y a plus d'échecs
aussi il y a un problème en plus par là
il y aura ici ça va être terminé ça a
été abandon en fait
abandon de Ali resa avant même que ma
niche joue son coup mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a plus d'échec je menace une
découverte ici et je menace juste de
pousser des pions c'est terminé en tout
cas grosse grosse partie de tes deux
joueurs Magnus qui qui est passé à très
très proche de standard coller juste au
début il y avait on va revenir un peu à
la partie parce que c'était un truc de
fou cette partie
et apparemment alors le gars m'a le gars
m'a manqué
de MP3 attaque la tour qu'est-ce qui se
passe et qui se bouge ma tour
genre là la cabane est proche je sais
ah ils ont fout des 8 derniers ok j'ai
fout des 8 échec qui va permettre de
gagner la dame découverte qui va gagner
la dame ok si je joue pas tout raciste
que je joue contre qui avait pris un ou
deux fourchettes
il prend la tour
et si je mange comme celle-là
il va jouer cavalier B5
qui est quasi forcé
qui menace de nouveau ça
et en plus des échecs sur la case noire
apparemment le seul coup
c'est ça
c'est le seul coup et ici dans mes armes
de fou ça te va cette position elle est
beaucoup trop dure le seul coup de la
position ici il a un trouvable
je comprends rien je comprends rien le
déclare
moi je dis bon bah je peux manger
naïvement cavalier j'ai un pion de moins
mais le roi noir il est complètement au
centre ça a l'air quand même pas mal
pour les blancs quoi
c'est fou c'est 7 qu'on veut regarder on
se dit bah écoute je gagne la dame
gratos ici tu vas manger la tour certes
mais je mange la dame bon ça a l'air
quand même pas mal ici mais le seul coup
des blancs qui gagne c'est un truc de
fou
je pense à un coup que j'aurais même pas
regardé quoi même pas anticiper s'il y
avait cette position
et c'est ouf
donc là il y a tous les coups qui vont
apparaître sur le chat et j'ai vu donc
tourgé
il a emprise
si tu veux défendre la tour ben moi je
veux cavalier enfin ça a l'air quand
même ça la ouf quoi et en fait l'idée
c'est que ce fou il veut le mettre là en
fait là où là
et c'est pour cette raison là que
que qui veut pas manger ici parce qu'il
perdait un temps
si je prends là tu es pardon
mais bon c'est tout dans 10 c'est juste
[Musique]
et là tu as B6 la dame maintenant vit
maintenant il y a un pion de plus pour
les Noirs non il y a oui il y a un pion
de plus
même deux pions plus pour les noirs
j'ai plus rien le fou il est là
c'est pareil en fait tu perds du temps
je pense
bien évidemment nous en tant qu'humain
on ne comprend rien et là elle résa elle
rigole mais enfin je pense en train de
regarder un peu ce qu'il a raté mais
c'est pas humain parce que c'est pas
humain quoi et c'est juste
c'est un peu de ouf dans cette position
de meilleur coup de la pollution c'est
orgère
ici franchement
[__] il faut avoir vu tout ce qu'il
faut avoir vu tout ça quoi parce que
moi je pense à ça c'est mon premier coup
tu fais quoi là
après ça tu manges là et quand on compte
le matériel bah ta cavalier fou moi j'ai
cavalier fou et du coup j'ai tout fou
cavalier pour la dame
donc avec je suis patient qui ressortent
mais bon j'ai plein de pions j'ai la
part de fou
apparemment ça c'est mieux pour les
noirs bien mieux pour les Noirs
d'ailleurs
soit 7 je pense un peu la même
mais pour les blancs
il dit non mais ça va tout va bien tout
va bien je suis content
et là il prend même pas ici il prendra
avec des fantômes
mais c'est bon c'est pas humain quoi on
est d'accord que c'est pas humain c'est
ça
c'est complètement fou et du coup pour
pour réfuter ça il faut avoir tout ça et
faire tourner
la tour géant maintenant tu as un
problème de problème trois problèmes
quatre problèmes même sans problème il y
a trop de menaces et là après F6 qui est
le meilleur coup qui donne une casse
pour le roi qui défend cavalier
maintenant fou à 7
sur dame là j'ai ça
même pas il fait ça
si je mange le cavalier il bouge
naturellement c'est quoi ça
c'est que deux pièces pour la dame ouais
bon c'est beaucoup trop compliqué mais
en fait voilà on peut dire que qu'elle
les réserves mais
franchement
c'est pas du tout humain et c'est la
porte de personne quoi même en partie
franchement c'est juste beaucoup trop
difficile
à calculer tout ça pour un humain la
force d'imaginer en partie bits même si
c'est Magnus c'est à dire ça c'est deux
des meilleurs joueurs du monde qu'est-ce
que tu veux trouver ça
c'est un truc de fou quoi ça c'est les
positions dans lesquelles l'ordinateur
il est il est mille fois meilleur que
que les humains parce que ils se
trompent pas voilà position ben il mais
juste en
[Musique]
pratique pour un humain c'est
introuvable c'est complètement
introuvable et et voilà donc je pense
que malus a eu raison de rentrer dans
cette position là sachant que ça va être
plus dur pour les blancs que pour
l'avoir c'est là on en parlait on disait
que c'était on disait que c'était
une position plus facile à jouer pour
les blancs que pour les Noirs parce que
pour les blancs c'est facile on attaque
on a accès à faire et pour le noir il
faut trouver des coups de défense mais
en fait c'était vraiment
au blanc de trouver tous les coups de
d'attaque et des coups hyper dur quoi
franchement bravo aux deux joueurs parce
que parti elle est juste trop bien quoi
mais bon trop difficile quoi
donc ça fait 2-0 effectivement ça fait
2-0 pour Magnus donc va y avoir une
troisième partie d'ici quelques instants
si Magnus ne perd pas cette troisième
partie et ben ça va s'arrêter là par
contre si ma venue se perd il y aura une
quatrième partie et m'amuse perd encore
et ben il y aura une cinquième partie
avec un armage donc c'est en deux et
demi vous voyez c'est écrit en haut le
premier à 2,5
donc donc voilà
ok alors je vais vous préparer la petite
scène qui va être ici parce que les
couleurs vont être changé ma vie ce qui
va prendre les blancs ici et je vais
aussi changer le support je vais enlever
le point de livraison désolé
c'est comme ça et de 0 pour Magnus à la
partie monstrueuse franchement
et c'est cool parce que franchement on
voit deux joueurs qui veulent se la
coller mutuellement et dans les dans les
deux parties
les rois ce sont envolés je vous
rappelle que la première partie c'est un
livret A son roi il est parti jusqu'en
jusqu'en H5 H4 avec les noirs et dans
l'autre partie et ben c'est normalement
qui part en 3 l'autre qui part en F7
derrière il met la F4 mais c'est que des
parties ou en fait ça joue vraiment
l'attaque à fond et je trouve que c'est
juste trop trop bien quoi voilà des
parties des parties ou des joueurs n'ont
pas peur et ont envie de slack coller
je trouve ça beau
bon c'est tout c'est écrit en dessous de
mon de mon de mon nom quoi
toi ma tête en dessous tu as marqué mon
nom et prénom et en toute marqué tout
pas très compliqué c'est écrit là
donc tout YouTube alors sur Youtube
c'est c'est tout fait chèque vous me
trouvez facilement si vous voulez avoir
plus d'informations d'ailleurs sur
twitch je suis stouf c'est écrit en bas
ceux qui auraient envie de me suivre sur
mes chaînes perso salut poignard
j'espère que tu vas bien
et oui c'est mon prénom
[Rires]
et la partie a commencé enfin va
commencer dans un instant Magnus a les
plans dans cette partie
on dirait un ah non c'est le slash c'est
le slash stouf
pas du tout
salut grand maître
voilà c'est ça
alors ça va commencer on est bien dessus
et avec deux zéros hier Magnus attention
il y a un Magnus contre contre carwan il
a commencé avec 2-0 en sa faveur il a
perdu une partie
puis
[Musique]
la deuxième partie tu es au bord de la
défaite et il a réussi à pas la perdre
mais malgré lui a failli de voir joindre
Armageddon alors qu'il venait de 0 de
base
pourquoi il y a deux u parce que je peux
te créer un compte avec le U avec un
seul U et après
c'était impossible impossible de
retrouver mon mon compte et même mon
adresse mail enfin j'ai tout perdu et du
coup ça j'en ai eu marre de chercher
j'ai dit ok je mets de lui on s'en fout
et c'est pour ça que j'ai deux eu à mon
compte mais c'est tout bête vous allez
partir sur abruti et vous aurez
totalement raison mais
ils sont de ma vie voilà
alors française de la part d'Ali resa
alors elle arriverait qu'il change hein
française c'est vraiment
est-ce que malgré nous faire l'attaque
norvégienne dans cette partie
mais oui c'est vrai plus tard la vache
d'offre qui s'est quand même mal passé
pour pour aller raisin c'est normal de
changer
donc cavalier
qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici alors il y a
plein plein de possibilités il va
falloir il y a E5 et full 5 c'est
vraiment les deux grands coups et on
joue au 5 F4 OK
généralement cavalier F3 cavalier 6
qui est joué il y a assez ce qui est
joué il y a faux aussi
quasiment tout est possible d'ici même
si c'est joué
beaucoup beaucoup de possibilités pour
les noirs
[Musique]
mettez perdant mais c'était hyper
compliqué lis ça franchement
à lire hasard à rater un à fait la
précision en fait derrière c'était quasi
la perfection
mais le coup qu'il a raté pour gagner ce
qui est le truc d'ordini c'était un
calcul là tu regarderas le replay si tu
veux mais c'était
un niveau de calcul juste
énormissime quoi truc
c'est les positions
n'arrive pas à contrôler c'est juste
trop difficile alors faut le 7 a été
joué là généralement il y a plusieurs
couples aussi bien à 3 qui a un coup et
souvent on fait aussi fou aux deux et
petit rock ni même des fois un monde où
des trois mais fou des trois dans la
française c'est beaucoup moins un jeu
que fou ou deux parce qu'on a moins de
contrôle de la case des 4 mais il y a
des cas quand même on peut jouer tous
les trois mais faut O2 ici est plus plus
logique il y a une vente que j'aime bien
pour les blancs avec du fouet
et plus tard des idées avec cavalier 1
pour je sais 3 et colmater ce petit
centre et ce qu'avait le D1 plus tard
hier en F2 G4 pour attaquer le roi en
angélique donc il y a plein de petites
idées comme ça qui sont intéressantes et
flotto avec tes jouets tout à l'heure je
l'avais dit mais fou ou deux c'est quand
même plus
plus normal donc là faire attention au
pire des quatre
et maintenant cavalier 2 pourra pas être
joué à cause de ces quatre des noirs
donc à voir
grand rock non c'est pas trop trop dans
l'idée révolte alors des fois on peut le
jouer mais généralement alors Céline là
les Noirs arrivent quand même
extrêmement vite donc c'est plutôt petit
rock et on joue après avec du F5 avec
lui voilà on peut se construire tu vois
on a une position qui est assez fermée
ici il y a une tension pour l'instant au
centre mais le jour on va réussir à
échanger depuis ton décompte le fiancé
par exemple moi je vais caricaturer mais
oups
le jour on fait un truc comme ça par
exemple et ben maintenant je pourrais ok
mettre le roi ici et un jour passer la
tour passer la dame vous voyez pour
attaquer par là-bas ou même des fois
réussir à jouer F5 en force et je suis
la paire de fou qui braquait sur le roi
donc pas mal pour attaquer avec avec les
blancs c'est 4 a été joué alors c'est un
couple je n'aime pas trop dans les
Françaises de manière générale parce que
moi j'aime bien des positions fermées
avec les Blancs et j'ai l'impression que
on a pas mal de jeux après par F5 donc
généralement j'aime bien les les blancs
ces positions mais j'espère que les
réserves à nous faire mentir dans cette
partie et ubsa donc là bien sûr c'est
vraiment juste suicide parce qu'il y
aurait des quatre qui arrivent très très
vite et moi serait en grand danger
directement F5 ça me coûte très osé et
F5 c'est un coup qu'on joue souvent
quand le pion des 5 n'est pas défendu
parce qu'ici regardez si on fait eux
prend les cinq
et on prend un pion sans frein plus tard
je pourrais bouger mon cavalier jouer
des cinq et ouvrir complètement la
position au centre et du coup F5 il a
profité du fait que le pion soit pas
protégé pour pouvoir faire F5
donc
super cool je pense de Magnus moi
j'aurais fait ça un tempo parce que
c'est le coup qui a l'air hyper logique
et après préparer un sac mais F5 dessus
tout à l'heure beaucoup beaucoup plus
fort en tout cas j'aime bien l'idée de
le faire maintenant pour vite ouvrir la
position alors ca va les laisser ce oui
mais je pense que je vais manger là à
faire petit rock et maintenant la
colonne 9
c'est pas quand tu prends là décision tu
prends du pion mais la [__] sera
ouverte où je prends du fou mais plus
tard ce fou il va voir son bien placé ça
à voir dans tous les cas j'ai petit rock
qui va arriver etc alors moi j'ai fait
une partie j'ai fait une partie une des
parties les plus belles de ma vie
sur une Française
une française comme ça
et c'était contre
contre Anna Rudolf pour ceux qui l'a qui
la connaissent elle est maître
internationale et elle stream sur
branche elle a sa chaîne je crois
d'ailleurs on arriveder et là sa chaîne
et elle est très connue sur les réseaux
et tout parce que elle a commenté plein
d'événements
liés aux échecs
et donc je l'avais joué à un tournoi en
Espagne c'était en 2010 et c'était une
Française un peu du même style et
j'avais sacrifié à deux pièces dans sa
gueule pour la mater donc c'était en F7
c'est un cavalier prend un S7 et un tour
prend j'avais sacrifié ma tour et mon
cavalier sur son bras pour la mater au
centre de l'échiquier et c'était c'était
une partie elle avait 2400 à l'eau et
moi j'avais 2200 c'est très longtemps et
c'est une des plus belles parties de ma
vie que j'avais fait il y a très
longtemps je sais plus si je l'ai fait
sur Youtube celle-là j'ai un petit doute
mais si elle est si je l'ai pas publiée
et ben je la publierai bientôt parce que
c'est vraiment une une très belle partie
que j'avais joué
et
il y a plein de thèmes ça te dit un truc
mais qui es-tu du coup
qualifio est-ce que je te connais
à commenter en live peut-être
parce que si tu l'as enfin si ça dit
quelque chose c'est que je t'en ai parlé
c'est-à-dire peut-être que je te connais
en vrai et comme je vous connais pas
derrière vos pseudo c'est pas toujours
si
ah t'as vu un de mes lives par hasard ça
marche OK
OK
parce que c'est vrai que si
tu la connais et que je n'ai pas mis sur
le tube je disais peut-être que tu
mais je crois qu'elle est pas sur sur
YouTube
donc
bon on verra en tout cas c'est une belle
partie que j'avais joué
contre elle sur sa structure
donc
[Musique]
alors qu'avait les essences qui a été à
jouer donc H6 c'est le coup que Magnus
attend dans l'idée en fait c'est que
cavale et Jacinthe sa menace pas grand
chose en soi mais l'idée en fait c'est
qu'après après après H6 et ben va jouer
cavalier H3 suivi de cavaliers F4 et le
Calvi qui va pouvoir venir sur ces cases
là ah c'est ça c'est ça oui je l'avais
commenté je l'avais commenté sur la
chaîne de skybloz il m'avait invité une
fois et on l'avait fait ensemble une un
petit cours dessus et j'avais montré
donc si vous voulez voir la partie vous
allez sur la chaîne de Skyblues de
YouTube et il y a une vidéo où il m'a
invité et j'ai montré cette partie lors
de la vidéo donc c'est plus quel est le
nom mais je pense que vous pouvez
trouver un stuff skybl blues vous
marquez sur google je pense que vous
trouvez assez facilement la vidéo
et
et voilà
[Musique]
ce flou blanc il est moche mais d'un
côté la structure reste intacte c'est
vrai que si on prend du flou le problème
de manger du fou c'est qu'un jour en
fait moi le faire le même plan petit
rock tout ça et ben il y a un problème
sur ce fout quand même qui peut être un
problème et aussi depuis on descend qui
va être un peu moins défendu parce que
le pion n'est plus là donc c'est un full
certes mais le fouillon sera plus actif
donc c'est vraiment le dilemme tout le
temps est-ce qu'on prend du Fou est-ce
qu'on prend du pion
il a production vers l'ordinateur vous
voyez il aime pas
mais c'est un dilemme tout le temps
c'est compliqué
dame 8 fougère problème sur
sur le pion le 6
et comment est-ce qu'on va s'en
débarrasser
dame G6
comment est-ce que je punisse ça
ah oui mais l'ordi il aime pas ce que
fait firou mais après l'ordinateur des
fois donc c'est pollution fermée et ben
c'est pas le meilleur des joueurs
autant dans la position tout à l'heure
tout était ouvert c'était hyper chaud
mais alors quand la pollution est fermée
c'est pas forcément le meilleur des
joueurs stockfish impec4 encore un coup
d’interrogation ça fait 4 d'affilée pour
pour Fillon qui n'aime pas du tout ce
qu'il fait alors juste pourquoi
il n'aime pas non plus je crois qu'il va
bientôt mettre un point d'interrogation
c'est la colère c'est la colère le stock
fish qui est tout rouge normalement
toujours pas ça
mais des 4 ah mais c'est encore une fois
c'est pas hyper compliqué le profondeur
là je suis en je suis en 24
je suis en 24 ça veut gagner ce comment
tu vas gagner
comment tu vas gagner ça un bail
donc ca va aller au 2 après il y a
encore eu un court raté la pression
tellement compliqué encore une fois là
il fallait jouer ça
et surtout prendre qu'à la logique
ouais ok super
des fois il fume l'ordinateur
c'est tout à fait normal F4
taper sur le pion aussi les blancs sont
extrêmement bien mais bon de la de la
dire que c'est un mauvais coup je pense
que stop fish il est fatigué aussi
il est fatigué
contre le vainqueur des loosers pour
revenir c'est bien ça tout ça
c'est bien ça on fera le point on fera
le point à la fin du à la fin du match
genre une fois sur 10 bah il y a une
partie très connue de Nakamura contre à
la box c'était pas stock fiche terrible
car donc il y a une partie de Nakamura
ordinateur je crois qu'il a fait bugger
tu veux une position fermée tu tournes
un peu toujours un pion tu tournes un
peu tu joues un pion et il a
complètement fait bugger l'ordi et à la
partie elle est assez connue je sais pas
si il faut la trouver sur le sur
internet en tout cas
il a fait bugger et donc c'est au marché
il y a moyen de trouver ça en tout cas
moi je l'avais vu
sur un
un article cheescom
je l'avais vu article regardez Nakamura
si mais à chaque 50 coups ils ont un
coup et le pire c'est que la partie de
ma caméra et le cas c'est le 3 + 0
,300 coups
vous savez mais
3 + 0,3 + 2 peut-être je sais plus mais
bon moi dans Comment vous savez qui
c'est
ripka c'est pas comme ça ceux qui
veulent chercher
c'est ben voilà c'est écrit au-dessus
c'est riche un Y et un B
271 ouais c'est un truc comme ça je sais
plus mais parti assez marrante
ici et là maintenant qui avait les
frères étaient plus possibles à cause de
dame prend dans le projet 5
ramener un peu les pièces gagner des
cases faire des menaces là par exemple
[Musique]
3 et ben je mange le fou G5
donc là il vient attaquer deux fois le
cavalier
deux fois mais il menace de venir là et
manger une un défenseur du cavalier G5
donc ça c'est malin quand même ce qu'il
fait il faut quand même le reconnaître
maintenant comment je fais
comment je fais pour ma venue comment je
me sors de cette pseudo combine je viens
de faire Ali casa
sur H6
peut-être
mais ça ça
va les prendre un tronc et
est-ce que tu bouges je prends là
je crois de la part de mamie
toujours ce cavalier F4 qui va qui va
sauter et H6 n'est pas n'est pas un
problème
attention là attention à l'ireza qui qui
est pas bien dans cette partie il est
mené de zéro
il est obligé de gagner la partie pour
revenir au score
donc là on a bien compris que les
raisins prend tous les risques pour
essayer de la gagner il vient de vos
dames G6 c'était quoi un peu bizarre
mais bon à un moment donné je suis
obligé de de d'essayer des trucs comme
ça
c'est la position est difficile
si je fais rien bah juste
je regarde les gens en même temps
j'aime bien voir un peu la tête des
joueurs quand il joue
qui va manquer d'oxygène chez lui
il manque d'oxygène ça se passe pas bien
c'est de norvégien vous voyez en dessous
air quality
peut-être que ça peut être la chance de
d'allier en cette partie
on peut espérer le malaise à la maison
si un malaise
on est d'accord
il a pris C3 il a récupéré le pion
E
sur le fou était sûr que tu en fou il
est pas un problème même si tu avais vu
que ça marchait pas le H6 par exemple et
ben c'est toujours comme soulager de
pouvoir chasser un petit peu la dame
noire
là c'est un petit peu ça c'est hyper
bien dommage 6 tu te mets en vis-à-vis
du foot tu sens que c'est c'est chaud
ce que je fais
il y a un truc comme ça qui était à la
clé
ça a l'air très suspect ce que fait les
raisins mais des fois encore à chuté car
elle prend aussi c'est ce qu'il a fait
j'avais dit ça non moi j'avais dit
l'autre c'est quoi la différence
pourquoi l'orateur là il aime bien
peut-être qu'il aura peut-être qu'il
avait peur l'ordinateur dans toute la
France
c'est le seul coup qui avait été 8 ans
pour pas perdre
je comprends rien
expliquez-moi je comprends rien
tu crois tu vas prendre la base il
fallait partir vraiment qui sont très
difficiles à comprendre niveau
calcul les cavaler prendre à 50 cordes
qui fait que des coups que des coups
des coups brillants
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe là il a
pris aussi
et en prenant un fou en G4 il a fait
Caval à l'écran
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe alors sur
d'un projet
prend E7 et sur cavaler prend le 7 j'ai
tout refuge qui fait mal
du coup tu peux pas manger le fou
malheureusement
tu manges ici je prends ici sur
l'échecourt
d'ailleurs là je pense que même ici
peut-être qu'il me reste plus qu'à
encore je pense ça va être un bourdon là
dans quelques coups là je crois que
c'est
qui a fait un match quand même assez
monstrueux franchement
et je pense à se voyait un dès la
première partie qui va gagner et tu
voyais que Manu c'était quand même hyper
en forme tu vois que c'était parti il a
joué une vitesse il a fini avec 10
minutes à la pendule il a écrasé quoi et
la deuxième partie c'était
c'était hyper hyper chaud mais en
défense Magnus
c'est un truc de fou quoi et celle-là
encore c'est une précision alors qui est
tout en l'air et il voit tout quoi
franchement impressionnant
après cela
c'est pas fini pour aller au hasard les
voisins reste en cours dans ce
dans ce
dans le tournoi après on va reparler un
peu de de du bracket et de et de comment
ça marche très rapidement un petit un
petit résidu dessus
mais vraiment là Magnus
c'est c'est très impressionnant
très impressionnant
fou B7
ça part le mat je crois mais tu as quand
même faire mater
un peu comment il va comment il va finir
comment on finit là comment on finit
il y a plein de coups qu'on a pas mal
tout à l'arbre
j'ai pas de tour Eiffel
c'est ça en l'air maintenant attention
calmement c'est pas si évident
marchera en PLS avec les Blancs ici en
venir attends mais j'ai rien je perds je
fais en PLS au pire ta foi je crois je
pense qui perd ta pièce qui défend un
peu tout mais en pratique c'est jamais
si simple
Magnus il a pas inquiet du tout par
contre
il a pas l'air il a pas l'air inquiet du
tout
qu'elle va les prendre aurait été
meilleur
ben je sais pas je pense que c'est
maintenant
les mêmes problèmes que tout à l'heure
et ça change pas grand chose pour moi en
fait
donc
solide le foot en prise on le bouge
c'est normal
et là il faut
il faut terminer un matin réellement
c'est vrai que Magnus a que un peu plus
on pourrait penser que c'est plus grave
que ça mais il y a qu'un pion de plus
sous le sens aussi une menace il y a pas
de menace là
S
mais
il faut gagner
[Musique]
solutions H6 c'est tout R4 qui peut
arriver
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de choses qui arrivent
même par exemple
mais bon c'est horrible il y a trop de
choses il y a trop de pièces sur le roi
en fait je suis hyper actif j'ai 6 ouais
en fait c'est possible
j'ai 6 au pire des cas j'ai foires je
crois au pire pire des cas et quand même
tout à fait
tout le temps être
un coup et là elle a pas beaucoup de
cases en fait
quand on a un vrai positionnel c'est
clair c'est pas le monde à faire ouais
je suis d'accord bah c'est vrai mais là
il a l'avantage positionné mais là il
est aussi en train de le mater donc là
il faut aller le mater sans prendre trop
de risques par exemple un coup comme
cavalier en G7 un truc comme ça sur la
peine à calculer c'est pas
[Musique]
c'est pas
l'idéal mais là vous voyez ça c'est un
peu solide qui défend les pièces on a
avantage d'espace matériel et puis enfin
l'avantage plus court j'ai fait deux
pions passer lié au centre des pièces
noires sont mal placées alors x 3 c'est
un coup intéressant peut-être dame
je suis pas fan d'échanger les dames
parce que j'attaque de maths mais bon la
potion tellement bonne
trop de menaces derrière non mais en
fait je gagne et le pire c'est que
Magnus en plus dans cette partie ben il
joue pour la nuit pour la nul entre
guillemets quoi
il sait que s'il a la nuit il va la
prendre parce que
[Musique]
il comment dire
il mène de zéro il reste deux parties et
donc si il fait nuit là c'est parti des
qualifier donc s'il a une nulle qui va
la prendre sans réfléchir en fait
voilà il va la prendre sans réfléchir
même si la partie bon clairement c'est
une partie c'est une partie où
il a quand même jeu pour le gamin
ça c'est clair
c'est nul il va chercher le gain je suis
pas sûr je suis pas sûr
en temps normal oui mais dans ce format
là où il faut juste une nulle pour se
qualifier je pense pas qu'il va qui va
se prendre trop la tête si il voit une
nulle directe c'est pour ça que Damien
ce qu'il a fait le juste avant je pense
à un super coup ça force l'échange de
dame et après changer la dame et ben il
y a plus de contre-jour pour les noirs
et du coup il est sûr plus perdre donc
il est quasiment sûr de se qualifier
mais là il a genre encore un coup
brillant Magnus c'est un peu cavaleron
G7 très joli alors bien sûr surprends
les Celtes il faut prendre les 7 et
surtout prends les cavaliers
ça c'est une tactique en
un coup qui est assez facile à voir pour
Magnus et ça va être ça va être terminé
il échange tout voyez ma vie c'est pas
la tête l'échange tout parce que c'est
plutôt opposé
et il s'en fout en fait les joueurs qui
sont partis d'ailleurs genre qui sont
partis
là le soupçonne Magnus d'avoir fait un
truc pour donner la tour et récupérer
ici
qui sont partis ce qui veut dire que
mamie n'a pas perdu
attention
quand même
je sais pas comment il va se débarrasser
parce que tout échec et roi là ça a
l'air qui
et c'est ma tante
qui pousse la tour qui est trop loin
pour revenir attaquer et Magnus Vienne
cette troisième partie d'affilée Margus
qui met trois zéro à lire et là c'était
vraiment hyper impressionnant au niveau
de Magnus aujourd'hui c'était juste
complètement ouf quoi je pense que 100%
dans le chat mais franchement c'est
c'est parti trois parties c'était juste
monstrueux monstrueux Magnus rien à dire
rien à dire
alors rapidement
le bracket il est ici regardez bien
alors je vous fais un petit résumé il y
a deux tableaux le tableau duo market
des gagnants et braque et tableau du bas
c'est droite des perdants des gens qui
ont déjà perdu un match donc Magnus
comme il a tout gagné et ben il va être
en finale oui la grande finale il est
pas encore écrit mais Magnus va partir
en grande finale et il va rejoindre le
champion du bracket du bas et à l'IRESA
qui maintenant est en et en finale du
bracket des perdants et à les réserva
affronter le vainqueur de
laserov et le vainqueur
de Furious Jura
plus adversaire
affrontera Magnus pour la grande finale
donc c'est possible que à l'IRESA s'il
gagne son match retrouve encore une fois
car elle sème dans la grande finale de
l'événement c'est possible donc on a
déjà vu plein de cas comme ça où les
gens en fait c'est limite dans le
tableau des gagnants et se retrouve en
finale ça n'a jamais eu plein de cas
donc Ali Raisa c'est pas encore terminé
pour lui donc en maths à faire et s'il
gagne son match bah il va revenir pour
jouer contre
quinzaine par contre
Sify
il gagne son match qu'il revient
concarne et ben il faudra le battre deux
fois pourquoi deux fois parce que Carcès
il a tout gagné donc Arsène il a eu
droit il a aussi droit à une vie donc si
qu'un scène gagnera son match contre
l'événement parce que deux fois contre
Magnus par contre si
Furious bac à et ben ils auront tous les
deux un match perdu et ben il y aura
encore un match pour
pour le gain du tournoi donc c'est là
quand tu perd 3-0 tu as pas envie de le
rejouer on a regardé aussi
premier match il a battu Abdou 3-0 et
Abdou ben regardez il est en il est en
semi-finale du losers donc peut-être
qu'il y aura un match à dofiru en tout
cas je pense que Abdou il est favori sur
la dalik même si les avis qui fait quand
même un beau tournoi il a sorti il a
sorti tabac abeille Esso c'est quand
même pas rien et du coup il y a moyen
quand même que l'as vu qu'il fasse aussi
encore une fois une belle perf donc en
tout cas assez assez intéressant donc
pour moi je vais je vais m'arrêter là
pour aujourd'hui
demain on se retrouve à partir de 17h
pour pour les les finales des déperdants
en partant avant de partir j'aimerais
faire un petit raid je suis notre ami
oups
ne partez pas s'il vous plaît encore
on va partir faire un petit red sur
notre ami blu-if qui est un streamer
cheescom le redis part dans quelques
secondes merci à tous passez une
excellente soirée je vous dis à très
très bientôt prenez soin de vous et
demain 17h comme d'hab excellente soirée
à vous à bientôt ciao ciao